I bet she would take the shoes off,
throw them to the audience.
I love that bag.
And you put the youtube videos,
black and white that day,
or she'd take a gold chain strong.
Rip His shirt off.
I need to see this.
Go Jamie.
Young Jamie.
Bring up law loop.
A loop.
A 19.
I mean she was a fucking crazy bitch.
She came.
My mom was friends with all along,
but later on I grew up with his son.
We were young kids up in Spanish Harlem
and I would go up there and visit them
and she was crazy.
They even did a one woman show watch
large egg.
Why looppay the queen of Latin soul.
This crazy bitch.
Wow.
Can you.
Is it okay to sit?
They'll play.
It could inherit.
I don't want to get kicked off of
Youtube.
So many of us own this,
right?
Yeah.
Stressful on her shit.
Her shoes,
she throws it rings.
She just throws whatever is closest to a
look at it.
It just gets crazy.
It gets crazy.
What is it about Latinos?
Latinas?
About Latin people?
What is it about Spanish people that
makes them so passionate and crazy and
hot blooded?
What is it?
Is it genetic?
Is it culture?
Be Genetic.
It's got to be genetic.
You think so?
When you get 10 Cubans together or kind
of talents together,
Greek,
the volume goes up.
We're all from the same.
Something has to be something.
The volume goes up automatically.
Old Sicilians.
The volume goes up,
man.
What is it?
And then you have the Spanish thing that
is just fucking nuts.
Listen man,
right out in the open right now.
Say I'm as Cuban as can be.
Born in Cuba.
I don't mess with Cuban women.
Don't mess with Spanish women.
I just don't.
I love him to death.
You talked to a lot of Jewish people
guys.
They'll say,
I love being a Jew.
The whole thing.
I don't mess with Jewish women.
They just don't.
You grew up with your mom.
You know what you're going to get.
You think about your mom and we'll,
we'll put up with her shit.
You know your mom is Sicilian whole
school.
You know,
it's different,
man.
They yell,
they scream.
You don't want to put up with that.
My mom was pretty calm.
Her mom was a yell or scream or yell or
scream.
Uh,
if there's a problem,
sweet.
The saints get called once to say it's
called,
you got a problem.
What did I do to deserve this?
But,
uh,
no.
I,
I can't.
Uh,
it's too much.
It's just too much,
man.
Too much passion.
The shoes come on.
People getting yelled at.
I don't dig it.
People throwing shit at each other,
but you get those spicy Latina is,
you know,
narrow zeroed in and you get them where
they're fucking savages.
If you control that into sex and all
that,
it's fucking probably savagery.
Like I said,
I've been with one Spanish girl and I
moved on enough that that's how good the
pussy was.
I got left back seventh grade back.
I stopped going to karate.
I stopped to church
and that was just dry humping and,
and feeling her tits.
Can you imagine if she gave me that
monkey in the seventh grade?
That would have been fucking walking
dead.
Do you remember how overwhelming it was
the first time you were with a girl?
Overwhelming.
You'd never had any sort of feeling like
that in your life and now it's just
overwhelming,
completely overwhelming,
and then you have two sets of friends.
Do you have the logical friends and then
you have animal friends when you're 13,
so I had friends that would go,
that's nice.
Where are you guys going to go to a
movie and then you have the fucking
heavy duty.
Adam,
what are you going to do?
Finger motion?
Yeah.
They're like,
what are you going to do?
You got to fucking grab or make out what
the right number.
They just tell you what to do.
You're lost.
You completely fucking lost when you're
13,
but how great is it?
The fall in love and hold hands and go
to the movies and go get a slice of
pizza.
When I was 13,
I lived in this place called Jamaica
plain and it was like a at.
It's becoming more gentrified now,
but at the time was kind of sketchy.
We had some kind of crazy neighbors when
this one kid,
his name is Paul Hudson,
he lived right next door.
Poly Hudson was my age.
We were both like 13,
but he was like 30.
He was like a 30 year old,
13.
He knew a lot of shit.
And I remember one time he was talking
about I hadn't,
I hadn't even come close to sex.
I don't even know if I had kissed a
girl,
like maybe like a little pack or
something like that at 13 Paul yachts
and probably fucked 100 girls by that.
I'm not kidding.
It was an animal and a and he,
we were talking and he goes,
uh,
somehow or another it got on the subject
of how a penis enters the vagina,
how it gets in there.
And uh,
and he was telling me,
it goes up,
you go up in a and I go,
you go up in there.
And he goes,
you ain't never fucked a girl,
have you?
And I'm like,
no,
I definitely haven't.
Like,
I didn't want to admit it,
I'm sure.
But if it was fucking obvious,
I didn't even know that your Dick went
up.
I thought it went straight in.
We all do.
I just found that out now and I'm 53.
I didn't know the up and I literally
thought I could never figure it out in
my head because I was like,
well,
I kind of know where the vagina is.
Like how could it work?
Going straight through it.
It doesn't make any sense.
But that's literally what I thought.
I thought you went straight in.
I thought it was like a belly button,
like the thoughts you have about sex or
man or young woman got to be.
You don't know.
Yeah.
You can't figure out why they do that.
You're so confused because he didn't
have any of those thoughts to three
years ago.
Like you're 10 and you're just thinking
about comic books and you know,
all this stuff.
You think about when you're 10,
you know,
what do you like to do?
You like to go fishing or something,
you know,
just hanging out with your friends and
then all of a sudden you're 13 and your
dick is hard all the time and you're so
confused and when you're around girls
they hug you and your follow.
Your body's just overwhelmed.
The smell of their hair and just being
around them is so attractive.
You know,
like,
Holy Shit is this
first time you sneak up behind a girl
you're behind and you smell her,
her harrison,
your mode.
You've got like a fucking anxiety
attack.
Like what the fuck is this?
Was that close to you and touch you?
And then you have the.
Did you have somebody who broke sex down
for,
you know,
like,
like we had a dude in my neighborhood
always at war.
Taos name was Puerto Rican Nelson and he
lived in the back of a thing and we go
to him.
It started with him fixing our bicycles
and we evolved with him.
So we want it from playing baseball on
the street.
And he would come out,
he was a bartender at night.
He would come out and throw balls with
us.
And with football,
and that's the guy you go up there and
you go,
hey man,
can we talk to you tonight?
Because firstly introduced us to weed,
right?
He was like,
you guys smoke weed?
And we're like,
Nah,
we ain't have no.
He sold us like seven joints for five
hours.
So he became a dealer and then the next
level.
Which girls.
So we asked them,
what do you know,
what do we do about girls?
And he would yell at us.
You guys never fucked what kind of
little facts on,
you know,
he would just fucking say a bunch of
shit.
And then,
uh,
it got to the point,
we have clinics at this house.
We go,
can we come over tonight?
Yeah,
better be quick.
What time?
Seven 30.
We come over and we'd go,
Nelson,
we have to take this girl out.
What do we do?
And he break it down,
take it to the movies you pay,
but then you wanted more,
you know,
what do we do?
And he's like,
all right,
I'll teach you about sex.
Come around to my window till about
8:00.
I'm going to fuck my girlfriend,
I'll let you look like shit like that
creepy shit.
Then we actually got went over there and
they listened like shit like that.
And we would ask them about come like,
what's come due?
And he would tell us it pregnants
degree.
He was like a in the seventies there
wasn't no sex education in schools.
Doug.
So you had to get it.
Where the fuck you got it right.
So you didn't have that in Boston?
Absolutely.
I didn't have any uh,
uncles that are friends like the Hudson.
No,
he didn't make me nervous.
I tried to avoid him.
He was real.
He was too street for me.
That kid,
there was a couple of kids like that.
There were two street for males or oh,
that's when I really realized that I
need to learn how to fight when I moved
to Jamaica plain because I was super
nervous skies or pick on me and I had no
idea what to do.
Like if anything went down,
I had no idea.
Like my Stepdad was never into violence.
Nobody ever explained to me how to even
punch or hold your hands up correctly.
So cool.
I got to learn something,
so that's when I started getting into
karate and I was into movies before that
I'd taken like a Kung Fu class or
something like that once when I was like
maybe eight years old and I lived in San
Francisco,
but it really know martial arts to speak
of and this neighborhood.
I was like,
fuck,
I got these kids are scaring the shit
out.
When was this to make a plane in New
York?
Now it said Boston.
Well this is a suburb of Boston.
Not a.
not a suburb really.
It was like a.
it's an inner city area,
but it's just at the time it was at
least just kind of a poor neighborhood,
but apparently now they have some nice
bars and restaurants and you know,
housing prices so expensive.
Someone a chance on the outskirts and
they start pushing those bad
neighborhoods away.
They start building up and own and they
become gentrified and you'd get a nice
house in a nice neighborhood for a good
deal.
So a lot of people,
you know,
that's a giant problem with New York
right now.
People just keep talking about it in
Brooklyn.
Brooklyn's just being bought.
Really.
It's,
it's so expensive to live in Manhattan.
Have you ever tried to look at real
estate?
If you ever fantasize,
maybe I'll move to New York for a couple
of years.
Like Arusha,
fear your thought about doing something
like that.
I have.
I thought about it.
I looked at housing prices.
You're like,
what are you talking about?
That's not $5,000,000.
That's an apartment.
How was that?
$5 million.
Do you ever yard?
Is there a.
is there something I'm missing?
Like what the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
It's apartment.
It's an apartment,
but they're stupid expensive,
like regular rent.
People were talking to him about their
regular rent.
They were talking like $3,500.
I was like,
what?
Like a regular comic.
Like not someone who is doing great now.
Like at Jim Norton or something like
that.
Just a.
A regular comic has got a one bedroom
apartment.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
how the fuck do you pay that
every time heavy to live in that city.
For me to afford to live in New York,
had to live down the shore.
What'd you do that do you think you'd go
down the shore?
Long Island.
I would go down the shore because I'm
familiar with it.
Right.
I would go like route 17,
Marlboro around there and they got
Chinese restaurants to the old school,
Italian places.
I'm saying it doesn't.
I'm already land.
Keep a place down there because we have
like a.
I think he's got like hoboken,
hoboken.
He has a house.
He has a condo or an apartment in
hoboken.
I think he's got a place down in the
shoulder.
He has a place down in this show.
Yeah.
I still deal with a lot of gut.
Bob Gunzel gigs down their apps and this
feels right.
This is a little away from where
everybody goes.
This is up from Toms River and seaside
and Belmont one.
This is Marlboro.
It still takes you off the 34,
35.
You still got to drive a little bit to
see the ocean and shit like that.
I just had a friend that lived there and
I liked the neighborhood.
I liked how the neighborhood was.
They had an old school Italian Delis.
You walk in stinky cheese,
blood,
saliva,
all that stuff.
A fucking tongue hanging upside down.
Wet books with water,
you know.
Let me ask you this,
Frankie.
Edgar's got to be the king of Toms
River.
Fuck yeah.
He's the king,
right?
King.
That's his place.
I haven't been.
He made me say Tom's river on a paper
view once.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like after you once say Tom's river
was like Toms River Shit.
Toms river is next to seaside.
Is it?
Yeah,
like close to seaside lava.
Let,
if I remember correctly,
because every time I'd be in seaside I
was in Tom's river.
Right,
right,
right.
I used to go to Tom's river.
What you do as you go down and you put
on some nets,
put those nets.
Like the kids.
I used to go down and we stopped by Toms
River.
There was a spot and you drop nuts off
and then you go eat and you come back
and you fucking pull out those clients,
those crabs,
Woo.
And they would go home and make a sauce
with the fucking crap.
Oh,
Katrina water.
That's the thing,
right?
The,
the sauce with crabs.
You don't really get that out and you
know,
it's very tough to make.
Like I don't know how to make it.
I just saw them do it.
I would never fucking dry because I
wouldn't trust her,
but they would just take the crabs and
put them in a fucking hall boil the
crabs and the tomato sauce sauce and
they like,
it has to shell breaks.
I don't fucking know.
I,
they get the flavor,
the meat.
I'm trying to remember if they pull the
meat out or if they left the clause in.
Sometimes it seems like sometimes they
just left the clause and everything in.
Right.
And you would have to get it out
afterwards.
You just have to suck it out after we
break the.
But you don't see that.
So it's pretty rare with like a red
sauce.
You'll see it a little bit in a nice
fancy Italian restaurant as a special.
Somebody comes in with those crabs.
You,
we have some nice grabbed for you.
There was a place that was a real good
place that was in west La.
It was a real good,
especially when it opened up.
It's called Il Grano and uh,
I think it just went under
unfortunately.
But this guy,
the chef as an artist man,
and he made this squid ink pasta with a,
with a crab sauce,
like a light tomato,
eat crab sauce where it was,
um,
I don't know which kind of car crab it
was.
Anyway,
dungeness.
That's what it was.
Jesus Christ.
It was spectacular.
It was like this black ink pasta that
was cooked perfect.
So you chew into it.
It's not mushy.
Doesn't just dissolve you like it's got
a little pop to it as you bite into it.
And the crab with the sauce.
It was fun.
One of my favorite dishes.
And what's the crab we get in Jersey?
Excited.
What's the dungeness?
Isn't it?
Is it dungeness?
Blue Crabs and Maryland,
right?
Isn't that?
I don't know shit about crabs and you
shut the fuck up because whenever I go
to Texas I get dungeness crab with the
salad and his Florida,
the place where they have those,
uh,
king king crabs or Alaska.
But then there's another big one.
Is that a rock crab rock?
Grab the ones with the big ass fat
clause.
What are those?
Stone crabs.
Stone Crab.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
All in Texas.
I think.
I'm not sure that's a get drunk sort of
move.
Be As.
Yeah,
he eat those things and you drink a
shitload of peers and your uncle gets
drunk and stupid shit and wound up
getting out of there.
But it's crazy because as a child I
could eat lobster.
I could eat any fish.
Fucking squid ink.
The one I could not eat was crap growing
up.
Why not sick?
Right off the bat.
I don't know why.
And somebody said it had something that
crab has something that make you sick.
I didn't start eating crab or maybe 15
years ago I couldn't eat a crap.
I liked the sauce.
I could take the sauce but.
But it had a skit.
I
had died,
I had done,
I had done.
Somebody said that's what it is.
It's heavy and I had died.
I don't know if it's true.
I don't fucking know what's in food.
And I put for years I couldn't eat it.
I started eating crab again Tuesday
nights at Meogie when we used to do
comedy there and they used to lip sync
in there and shit when they had one
little stone crab rolls and I didn't get
sick.
So I started eating it again.
Wow.
For years I get sick off grab every
time.
Anything else could go down,
crabs,
clams,
whatever.
I just went to Boston and I went to
legal seafoods and I got those big
fucking clams every dead and 12 and
Jesus,
little horseradish,
a little.
Oh my God.
Those things are fucking delicious
because you get the steamers with the
tails and shit.
You don't like those.
I love those.
You're making a face like it in like
steam is rough when you're eating that
butter,
dip those and butter.
It was the first day and I said whether
I'm going to switch a big fucking clams
cherry,
Cherry net.
Those are good.
Those are very good.
I think I prefer them over oysters.
Really.
The A to the oysters don't work for me.
The the clams have more snap when
you're.
When you're eating them raw.
It's interesting because we never
thought about it is that being Sashimi,
you know,
you're just getting clams or oysters,
but it's raw fish.
It's raw seafood,
seafood,
you know what I mean?
It really is.
How is that any different than,
you know,
getting raw scallops at a Sushi place.
It's kind of the same.
That is a weird thing that we just cook.
We cook almost everything.
We cook fish,
but there's spots we can go where they
don't cook it.
It's delicious.
Very good.
They just give it to you raw.
You go to Alaska.
I've been Alaska and get the halibut up
there.
Like when you get the.
I haven't gotten.
I haven't done that where it's fresh and
really raw.
Two different worlds,
man.
Halibut.
Sushi is really good.
I would imagine if you got it like right
off the fish,
it would be amazing.
Amazing.
Yeah.
It's weird that we have these sort of
rules like as far as like food
preparation and it just changed with
Sushi,
like think of this country up until
Sushi.
Like nobody.
There were no one's serving raw fish
anywhere until what?
I mean.
What year did she come out?
The eighties or something.
Seventies.
I remember Japanese restaurants in New
York said,
I don't remember Sushi.
Sushi.
She blew up.
I didn't try Sushi to Seattle like 95.
I still away from it yet,
but once I was in I was fucking all.
But I definitely remember Sushi when I
was a kid.
I remember it from when I was like 18,
19 years old.
I remember that.
So it had to be before then.
So man,
maybe it was like the seventies.
We think about it.
Culinarily speaking.
If you could do that,
that's a long ass time
with no Sushi.
A long ass time in this country all
those years with no Sushi.
And then all of a sudden Sushi now
you've been to.
Yeah.
And as the Sushi different in Japan,
I don't really know.
I couldn't say that honestly because I
went to a couple places,
I didn't go to a lot of places,
you know,
we were only there for the UFC so it was
pretty in and out.
But the Sushi that we found there was
like,
you know,
it,
it was,
you're in a Japanese restaurant,
has a totally different feel because
you're in Japan.
I mean you're in Japan,
the people can barely speak English if
they speak English at all.
The menus are all in both Japanese and
English was pretty cool.
And so one of the cool things about
traveling,
a lot of people speak English,
so there's a lot,
a lot of places you can go where you can
at least sort of get by.
They speak enough English so you can get
by.
And uh,
that's uh,
that,
that's the case
since it's a weird thing,
man.
When Japan,
it's like,
if it's a totally different world,
like when you go to Japan,
like their culture is so interesting the
way they choose to behave like
collectively.
So interesting.
They're super polite.
They have giant crowds of people in the
streets and there's no issues.
Everybody walks by each other with no
problems.
It's like it's.
It seems like even though it's an
accelerated culture and obviously they'd
get a lot of shit done.
They make a lot of things.
It's they've giant businesses and it's a
small place.
If you look at how tiny it is now,
many people are stacked in there,
but they're super polite really.
I mean,
it's amazing how little crime,
how much order you have and then every
now and then you have these dudes have
come from other countries and decided
like,
oh,
this is an easy pickins place.
We were there.
We ran a two while we're walking into a
restaurant and we ran into these African
dudes trying to get you to go into these
massage places now.
Like super aggressive about it and
you're like,
Whoa,
this is interesting.
So you have all these polite Japanese
guys and then these really slick,
streetwise dudes have moved into spots
and you could see them sort of work in
these places,
but they're in Tokyo,
which is,
you know,
overall.
It just really,
really polite.
It's interesting.
It's really interesting.
Apparently I didn't experience it,
but apparently they have a rate that
really,
especially the older folks do not like
white people.
They just are not really into Americans
being around.
We bombed them.
Oh yeah,
I know.
I mean,
you think they gonna forgive us that
quick.
We don't think about that in our
generation.
We don't think about that.
That's why they don't need Vietnam food
for a long time.
I'm like,
we just fought them.
They want to poison this.
You want to go to that and a Vietnamese
fucking that rolls.
They just fucking poisonous.
I would poison you.
You know?
Yeah.
It's funny how the menus,
like what we think Chinese.
That's why I asked you,
because when we think Chinese food is
here is completely different over there
because it gets an Americanized and the
same thing goes for the Sushi.
Bob Sapp told me that when we're
shooting the longest yard,
he said the Sushi was more a little
primitive over there.
They'll come up with a fucking octopus,
you know,
like shit like that where there's a lot
of places that'll do that.
Jimmy,
I need a cup.
But when,
uh,
when uh,
you know,
I was watching something on food and
they were talking about a place in Japan
where you go get some type.
It's a place where they only serve food
that has an,
it's an aphrodisiac.
Oni,
like it's both balls and somethings I
balls or something.
So you go in there to get tuned up for a
date.
Like when you go to El Paso,
Texas,
okay.
If you go towards the end of a Paso,
Texas and get Mexican soup,
like you could hand fish soup.
There's a couple of heads in there with
the eyeballs looking right at you that
you wouldn't find that here in
California and have a fucking heart
attack.
But once you get more towards the
country itself,
they start showing that culture like we
don't know anything about both balls.
It's something to do with bolts and
what,
how they put it in a soup or something.
It's a special of the day and the women
can eat it also,
but it just becomes something different.
That's what I was.
That's what I was asking you about the
food.
Well,
the one place that we went to,
we went to at least two Sushi places,
but one place we went to,
it was supposedly a great place.
I think bordain might have recommended
it to me name drop,
but when we went in there it was just a,
you know,
same stuff that you get here really
fresh.
Really.
You know,
it was,
it was right out of the ocean I'm sure.
But that's the same thing here.
We share the ocean a lot of the same
fish,
but the Japanese fish people,
Japanese who she plays,
there's only buy from Japanese fish
fishing guys.
They keep it like my buddy sold fish
back east and I used to say them.
You don't feel that the Japanese people
know it's well known that that market
with the mafia ran a really.
When you go there in the morning,
you see the town and just see the white,
the Irish and the Japanese people
because they have different types of
fish and what they do with it.
I think.
I'm sure they have that poisoned
blowfish.
What they tell you not to eat Sushi went
on Mondays and some other debt because
the fishers old.
Oh really?
They always say the fish that comes
Tuesday and Thursday.
That's when you get sushis.
Don't eat Sushi.
I'm.
I don't know.
I don't like someone day.
How long can you keep Sushi before it's
terrible.
If you had to guess,
if you buy a big piece of tuna,
how long before you have to serve that?
I can't imagine.
It would be very long.
Very long now.
Like a few days at the most.
I don't trust fishing on trust pork.
A lot of times you got to be careful
with those two.
Those two.
Just a little slight McCook and you're
fucking in the hospital.
Not domestic pork isn't so much anymore,
but it used to be for sure freezing fish
for 24 hours,
allowing it to thaw on the refrigerator.
Reduce harmful bacteria.
Making the fish safer.
Oh,
I see.
That's interesting.
So they free.
Oh,
this is interesting.
Fish for a made for a fish,
for making homemade Sushi.
Should be purchased from a cmo longer,
not a local grocery store.
That's interesting.
What's the seeming?
See Maga is a dude who goes and buys it
straight off of the boats and he only
has like,
he has it that day.
There's a guy used to train with in
revere who is a younger who would come
and take taekwondo in my class and this
dude had a truck and he would drive his
truck to the boats and you know,
negotiate a price and buy fish and then
deliver that fish to restaurants.
Like that was his thing.
It's really interesting because we
talked about it and you know,
he was telling me how,
what a grind it was like,
Whoa,
how much work is involved and what it
does.
I mean he just works.
He was getting up early.
Early.
Yeah.
In the morning,
the morning you put an App,
would you tell them you go to like 20
restaurants and you'll listen?
I have salmon.
I got my Ma and I got the yellow tail.
That's my fucking shit.
Yeah,
you pull it out,
but let's say you're a column my
restaurant and you sell 25 pounds a day
of,
you know,
for.
I liked my.
Where I grew up.
Rudy's Rudy's is basically a columbine
restaurant.
People go in,
that's the appetizer they buy 50 pounds
a day.
They probably got three different guys.
They go through.
Wow.
And Chris was one of them,
you know,
he was Italian and they,
you know how to cook it.
So he would go over to.
He had a great job for years.
Man,
you know what happened?
He got smart and that's what happened.
He got smart when he kept it simple,
his was very easy.
He went to restaurants.
He said this is what I have really good.
And he gave him a car with a phone
number.
He got up at three in the morning.
He pressed the machine and this is joe
from Rogan's,
let me get 25 pounds of column on 10
pounds,
the yellow tail.
So all he had to do now is add up.
So he would get your 10 pounds squared
is 20 pounds is 30 and Sarah,
I need 100 pounds of squid.
He would go down there and there's
people that actually cut a deal for
that.
You know what?
I want this a pound to 100 pounds.
I'll give it to you for this.
His money changed every day.
It's money changes every day.
So once he go to the boat by it and then
they delivered it and that was it.
No overhead,
no real insurance,
no freezers,
no nothing.
Anything he had left over.
That's what he went to come to his
family to cook.
What happened was he went partners with
a guy got a freezer.
They stocked up on the fucking food.
They stocked up on the fish and New York
had a power outage.
He lost 60 grand.
That was the end of everything.
He lost 60 department,
lost like 80 [inaudible].
They went on,
got got bones and spent all this money
on wholesale.
You and I both know it's a daily thing.
Yeah.
That's a daily thing.
You been making a living for 10 years on
a daily.
Now you want to think about the future
and buy a bunch of fish and that's the
night that like a week later the power
went out.
When he moves into his warehouse,
he had to go there in the middle of the
night and fish ice things.
You got to take stuff out and ice.
Him and Jesus.
Yeah,
they didn't have such good insulation
back then either.
How long has the power for like 12 hours
that time in New York.
This school I'm telling you 10 years
ago,
you know they have coolers now that to
keep things like they keep ice for seven
days outside.
We've seen these coolers.
No,
they're crazy.
They're like,
there's a bunch of different really high
end coolers and most of it was started,
at least to my knowledge by this company
called Yeti and Yeti coolers.
They make these outdoor cores that
people use when they go camping or
something like that.
They're real thick and you put ice in
those fucking things.
You close the lid,
open that lid and seven days there's
going to be ice in there.
It's crazy.
The insulation properties of these
things are nuts.
I just,
I don't.
They have a seal like your pull down
these rubber straps to seal it in.
They're not cheap.
They're fucking heavy shit to.
They're really heavy.
You know?
Most coolers are really light.
These things are not like you want your
eyes to fucking safest days.
They're crazy though.
It's crazy what they can do.
Like they somehow or another figure it
out,
some insulation method that retains cold
for a long time,
but they didn't have that shit in the
seventies.
Imagine the Ice House in Pasadena used
to be an ice house.
Used to be a place where they would
deliver ice and you would go and get a
chunk of that shit for your icebox and
you wouldn't have an icebox and
refrigerator and that's where you keep
your milk and whatever you're going to
eat that day.
But you went to the market every day.
Feiss yeah,
we went to the market for ice when maybe
I use every few days,
but you went to the market everyday for
food.
Like you don't,
you just,
you didn't just have like a
refrigerator.
You open up,
pull out packages of meat packages,
chicken like that.
Nobody did that.
This is really rare.
Like when there was no refrigeration.
Think about that.
That's not that long ago.
For most of human history.
There's been no refrigeration.
That's why people used to go to war for
salt.
Joey,
they used to go to war for salt because
salt was how you could keep your food
fresh.
You'd have to take a piece of meat and
cover it with salt,
cover it completely,
and that would keep bacteria from
growing on it.
That's how they took care of their meat.
That's like they would salt their fish
when they would go to see they,
they,
the salt would be so valuable.
So like there was salt wars in the world
for fucking salt,
which is worth nothing now.
Just crazy.
Like if you went all in on salt back
then and was like,
dude,
people are going to war for this shit.
And then today you went to a diner and
there they have little packets.
You can just take them like you could
take them,
go to in and out Burger.
There's a whole box,
how can I take you?
Take as many as you want.
You can take as much salt as you want.
What are you fucking crazy.
You'd call your Viking friends.
They're given salt away at the Burger
place.
It would just come in there and steal
all the salt.
Salt back then would you kill people for
salt?
Because that's how people like it would
allow you to keep food longer,
which is insane.
Like that was like imagine to war for
refrigerators.
You know Japan had the refrigerators and
we didn't know there was a war to try to
get refrigerators is the only way you
keep.
Keep your food longer.
That's literally what people were doing.
They were going to war for salt.
When you watched the honeymooners,
they drained the refrigerator.
Now I figured out why it was an ice
cube.
She would pick the thing up and drain
in.
The honeymoon is and that's why they
probably put an ice cube and now they
close it.
That's how they do what the honeymooners
though was electrical,
so they probably did have refrigerators,
but a lot of those things would freeze
up.
The ice box is you'd have to defrost
them.
Do you remember that?
Yes,
they would.
They would.
Fucking freezer would literally be like
the inside of it would be like,
like a an ice cave?
Yeah,
like a Yeti's ice cave and a monster
movie.
Now you have freezes.
Freezes.
Well they call them something that you
freezers don't.
Isis freezers.
They don't.
You don't have to defrost them.
Right,
but we used to chip out them with a
screwdriver and fucking hit.
When I was a kid,
I used to use my air conditioner a year
round,
like my mom used to call you fucking
crazy.
I'd put the air conditioning in my room
year round and it would get a brick of
ice on it.
I'd have to.
Wow.
That's what happens when you put it on
the window.
I guess the inside refreeze freeze,
I'd have to turn it off and let it come
down a little bit.
The inside,
we're fucking freeze them.
Those old school heaters.
That would make noise when they were
starting up like clank clank,
clank pills,
radiator heaters,
really tap,
tap,
tap.
It was this hot fucking chunk of metal
in your house and if you leaned on it
would sear your skin like a George
foreman grill and that's how you keep
your house warm.
Remember those goddamn things.
Those are ridiculous metal things.
Those heavy.
You would pick one of those
motherfuckers up.
Fuck those radiators,
man.
Does water heaters.
Hot Water would go through them and they
would heat up and that's what you use to
keep your house warm.
Those things were ridiculous and you put
a box over them and even if you sat on
the box by mistake,
you'd fucking burn.
Yeah.
And the only thing in your fucking house
at all would be like within 15 feet of
that thing.
And they always put them under the
window.
Exactly.
They would put the heat under the
fucking window.
Like I never figured that.
So you'd stand there and get burned.
But there was like a draft or some shit.
Yeah.
They didn't have anywhere else to put
it.
You couldn't put them in the middle of
the roundabout,
those metal fucking thing.
You know,
you get like a house,
like the last house I had it and the
studio said he had no fucking heat.
Why when they built that no fucking heat
because they didn't think people in
California,
and you know those burbank houses,
those old houses that didn't have heat
or they put a little box like you're
only gonna to use it.
Let me tell you something.
When you come out of the shower,
you need to eat.
I don't give a fuck who you are.
When you come out of that shower and you
turn that water off,
you need to heat.
That's a trick they do in Topanga.
There's a lot of
houses,
independent candidate,
don't have air conditioning like you
don't need it.
Maybe you need one or two days.
Fuck you.
I don't live walk.
That breeds people invite you over.
Meanwhile you're fucking melting that.
What's coming out of yet and like we
don't have the air.
We leave the windows open.
It's sort of fuck you put.
You should have told me this on the
invite.
I wouldn't have came and we have
nowhere.
We lived by the fucking,
but I wouldn't have came.
I want to add,
I got to have something.
You got to hit me with some.
Some people like to have like a thin
sheen of perspiration on them all the
time.
No,
Shane,
you got to have a little bit of add
something to something.
I don't want my hands to freezing.
I know what you mean man.
I agree with you.
One hundred percent.
You know that shit works from Colorado.
Like when I lived in Colorado.
You Do,
you leave your window open one inch and
your house will fucking freeze to death
in the winter.
Just one inch.
That shit don't happen to hear.
That never happened here.
I'm always fucking warm in that.
These people say,
well the breeze dries.
You don't fucking do nothing for me.
Well,
it's nice sometimes,
but if it's 98 degrees and Dick and that
happens,
that happens.
I mean it only happens a couple of days
a year,
but it happens,
but it happens that day.
You invite me over to the house and
watch the fight to something and that's
the dad go fucking ape shit.
It just seems like why would you have
such a big nice house and not have air
conditioning?
Like I've seen people's houses.
They're like,
this is a nice house,
man.
You got a great house but you don't have
air conditioning.
Is This A.
is it a money thing?
Is going environment be different and
break my balls,
but
that's what they want to do.
They want to be different.
I'm like,
we don't live off of.
And then they start making excuses for
her while the something factor in their
raises your cat can't.
What the fuck you talk on them.
I just want to be comfortable a little
bit.
Is a air conditioning bad for you?
I've never heard of air conditioning is
bad for these people will find something
bad for it.
There's certain people that find
something,
but
I can't get a tattoo joe because I can't
see needles,
but I'll tell you that off the bat.
There's people that'll say they hate
that.
Those why do you hate?
I just hate that.
You don't hate that [inaudible].
You can see fucking blood so you can't
get it that though.
That's why.
Yay Them.
I just hate needles.
When I went to the doctor yesterday,
she goes to me.
Uh,
all right,
so I'm going to give you the steroid.
I'm gonna give you this for you.
He is.
She goes,
I'm going to give you the shot.
And she goes,
no,
I'm not.
And she goes,
I remember the surgery.
You're a fucking nightmare with needles
and shit when it comes to all that.
So they couldn't find the vein.
This surgery.
That's a fucking nightmare.
Three plugs.
That drove me.
I was ready to go home.
Listen,
if you don't find the vein this time we
go home.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm done.
You poke me three fucking times.
Every time I faint.
Let's do the risk.
Look at these fucking veins in here.
Finally she found the vein in my hand.
Look at that.
There's veins right there.
I hate all that shit.
Needles.
Blood.
Soon as I walked into the doctor,
checked my blood pressure before I walk
into a doc.
That could be 1:30 over 80.
I walk into
a doctor's office.
It shoots up the one 90 over fucking
1:30.
Yeah.
We always look at people who do drugs
intravenously,
like that's next level.
That's next level.
You're shooting it up like you're.
You're opening your vein with a piece of
metal and you're injecting some liquid
in there.
Ooh,
that's deep.
Like you just threw all protocol out the
window.
That's why you.
If you ever hear about someone who's
like,
hey,
does coke?
When someone says,
this guy does a lot of coke,
I put them in this category kink.
Someone goes,
I got smokes a lot of weed and put them
in that quarter.
Paint.
Someone goes,
he shoots heroin.
I go,
oh,
this motherfucker goes over here.
This is a different role.
I something that you know how much pain
I had in my heart the first time I had
to put something in my nose.
I'm just not a good feeling.
It's not a good feeling.
I don't give a fuck with that.
I think about it now.
It's horrible.
You just made a big leap to being a guy
who does coke the first time I put some
in my nose or wasn't covered.
What was it?
It was angel toss.
It was the crystal.
It was,
you know,
they,
they called the TAC crystal,
the crystal.
That's what they call it,
but they didn't call thc like pot.
That's what you did in those days was
there was a thing that you took a bunch
of stems.
You got,
you took a pound of the stamps,
you got to pound the weed.
You took those stems,
you put them in a little bit of water
and you boil it.
The powder that goes to the end of the
thing that would scrape that up,
mix it with some color and then you can
snort that.
That was the beginning.
So I was okay.
Okay.
Some tea.
See Crystal.
So what does that do for you?
What does it feel like?
Because I feel like you had a smoke.
Yeah,
it feels like an adult,
but they got hip and they started
putting angel dust and gorilla
tranquilizers.
Fucking donkey.
Fuck.
And next thing you know you,
I mean I had a great time doing that
shit.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I love doing that crystal shit.
Yeah,
loved it to.
So this is the snorting,
snorting or smoking slump.
Essentially a edible cannabis,
but it wasn't.
No edible cannabis.
It's totally there.
It was gorilla biscuits,
right?
So you have two choices.
You can either go down to like a place
and buy for $10.
You got three lines when you're 16 and
15 each line,
the street hours make it.
Each line were high for 12 hours.
I'm how fucking 12 hours or eight hours
of heavy duty like the last.
If you had a.
well it's hard to tell now because your
tolerance is so high.
But if you had to compare it to like an
edible was,
is like a 200 milligram,
God,
compared to an edible 500 million gone.
God.
No,
no,
no.
It's just a different area.
It's like taking something that you
actually go to a different fucking
around.
It's not like doing an adult,
but I've done some edibles and I've gone
to different rums.
Don't get me wrong,
but first couple times you do the like,
one time I went,
I was working.
I graduated
high school.
This is the tail end of my tea.
Have my crystal Korea.
I wasn't even because I did crystal tea
from.
I was probably 15,
maybe 14 and a half up to the point my
mother died.
Then cocaine took over and cocaine just
said,
fuck all that shit.
And there was no more acid.
Cocaine came in that heavy in 1980.
So before 1980 you would snort.
You were doing the pills and you were
doing the fucking,
the thc crystals and all that shit.
But after the cocaine,
just want it.
So in 82 I graduated,
I was working in the city for this book
and I went over one day and they go,
listen,
we're not going to do the horses today.
My Dad can't come if you want to hang
out for the afternoon.
So I said,
fuck it.
I'll just take the day off.
I'll never forget this.
I went walking,
I saw some girl and I was walking into
one of those spots to get reefer.
I was going to get weed,
my day was over and let me get weeded
out and I don't have to come back
tonight from Jersey and some black girl
came up to me,
that'd be 10 in the morning and she
goes,
you want to split a tray?
I said,
sure.
A tray was at $3,
bag of angel dust.
So you opened it up and it was just a
little wine and you took it and sprinkle
that on your joint.
They sold the right there at the refit
spot.
Wow.
And you would roll it and smoking.
I smoked every 10 at 8:00 at night.
I remember taking a bus over from being
with her and going,
I'm still fucked up.
Like now I can talk like,
you know,
at the end of the day when we,
because we smoked it and then we just
sat there and talked to all of that and
three hours.
Then she told me she was pregnant.
Wow.
And that's what she.
I got pregnant and she opened up a
jacket and I could see her belly.
Oh,
I didn't know before that.
I never forgot that.
I never forgot that,
but I remember going over the fucking
bridge and going to a bar and going,
if I'm still fucked up at 9:00 at night,
whatever,
and that baby like,
man,
that's fucking crazy.
That is fucking crazy.
Wow.
We just went to a park and sat there and
talked and read the Daily News and the
fucked up whether,
I don't know if we went to eat.
I don't remember what we did with Sachs.
Nothing like that happened.
We just hung out all day.
We were that fucked up.
That's the crazy thing about being born.
You can't pick your parents.
That kid just got a shit roll the dice
is mom's doing angel dust.
Damn.
Anybody that gets
like loses their perspective.
That's a real perspective enhancer right
there.
That idea,
that poor kid and that poor girl that
she's so fucked up,
whatever happened to her,
led her to become that kind of person
takes angel dust while she's pregnant.
Fuck man.
Oh,
oh my God.
So weird.
Like we know things are bad for us,
but the feeling it gives you feel so
good.
You want to do bad things to yourself.
It's a little trick.
It's like this bad thing to you.
That's piggybacked on a good time.
It's like it gives you a good time.
It's like,
I'll give you a good time.
He let me poison you.
How much have a good time?
Oh,
you got to remember a lot of fun times.
I'm going to poison you though.
Okay.
Like,
okay.
Okay.
Now let me.
I'll get off it.
Eventually you'll get off of it.
You're for sure.
Going to give you a good time and it
just latches a hold of you and to you
and your lovely poisons out there.
Joe From Mcdonald's to steroids.
I mean,
emily,
do you want me to say what the is the
worst?
The worst right now.
Cigarettes.
Really?
When I shot that special,
I was smoking reefer outside.
I didn't want to smell like refund.
When I went in and there was a cop and I
took a cigarette from somebody.
I'm like,
I light and I just took to it.
Some of it [inaudible].
I felt it the next day.
Really like,
I'm like,
this is hard.
When you don't smoke for a long time and
then you smoke,
you're like,
oh shit.
Because I tell you what,
Joe.
Hi.
I live on the deep end.
From time to time I'll have a duis and
ginger ale or on a flight somewhere,
you know,
an alcoholic drink belts and fucking run
with me for 12 hours.
Bro.
Don't drink alcohol like everybody.
A big drinker.
No,
but I like it.
I liked the taste.
The doors and Ginger Ale.
I like Irish cream on the rocks.
Whatever the fuck it is.
You know,
I came in before I was early and I was
looking through your whiskey thing that
Jack Daniels is Sinatra at.
Smells fucking tremendous.
Want to do a drink?
Not in a million fucking years.
I'll drink.
Affects me completely different than it
affects anybody.
I drink one of those.
I can't drive home.
I got to sleep in here.
Really?
I can't.
I can not drink and drive.
It's against always.
I always fucked me up like that.
Watching.
Maybe that's why you don't like booze.
It's like it has a stronger effect on
you.
Maybe do.
I don't like boosters.
I grew up in a bar and saw the
different,
you know,
you and I have a common knowledge that I
talked about the ad that I'm going to
point my life.
I can't take drunk people,
but I'm going to be honest with you.
I couldn't take drunk people and I was
20.
I was just drunk and doing drugs,
so I understood them.
Now when somebody comes up to me drunk,
I don't know what the fuck you talking
about.
It's a,
it's a hard time when you're sober and
they're drunk and they're insistent on
talking because you're in two different
frequencies and their frequency is very
awkward to you and you don't.
They don't realize that they're being
awkward because they're drunk.
You know,
it's part of the problem.
So some people are great drugs,
some people,
you know,
they'll have a few drinks and you never
noticed a thing.
They're just happy having fun.
Like Brian Collins.
Good example that he ever see Brian
Count drunk.
No,
even when he's drunk,
he's just Brian Cowen drunk,
you know,
he's just having fun.
Just being silly,
you know,
he uh,
he maintains his character,
you know,
some people don't
and there's a certain people that they
get drunk and you have to talk to if
you're sober and they were drunk.
It's like,
wow,
this is,
this was getting nowhere.
You can't.
Yeah.
They just don't get it.
They don't understand that that's the
big problem with being drunk because
you'd almost,
you know,
you're drunk,
but you don't really know how.
You sound so terrible.
There's just no way.
No Way.
Totally know how goofy.
Look
everybody's drunk.
You're fine with one person,
so like,
oh,
this is so stupid.
Yeah.
But I realized how fucking Shitty I felt
the next day or half a cigarette,
like three pops.
I threw it away.
Like the next day I could feel in my
body,
I could still taste it.
And you'll ball while you're doing it.
You have no fucking idea.
You know why you're doing all that shit.
You know how bad his coke.
We used your central nervous system.
It's why you're doing it.
You don't give a fuck.
Jesus Christ.
It gets to your bones.
Yeah.
I remember you saying that that was a
great way that you described it like Joe
Rogan.
It's in your bones.
When you talk to an addict and say to
him,
how come you can't get off?
They'll say to you,
man,
this is a pain.
The withdrawal from heroin and even the
Oxycontin,
those bills,
that's a heroin.
You get to your bones,
your bones start to hurt.
You know?
I've spoken with different people.
I never had.
I never went through that with with any
drug,
but I've spoken to people off of heroin
when they kick heroin.
It's a horror show.
It's a fucking week long.
Iris show a puke and then that other
convulsions.
That's what you eat
and that I can't.
I,
I didn't do.
I did heroin,
but I snorted it the first time.
I fucking put that pattern,
my nose.
It fucked with me for awhile,
but I just put it in the back.
It,
you just put it in the back file and
then doing coke with something,
another complete harvest show for me
because I didn't mind doing drugs.
I just never wanted to do color.
What I did coke,
that was it.
I just like the first time I missed the
fucking credit,
but like the first time I could make a
credit card payment.
When I got divorced it ruined me because
it was against my principal who I was
like,
you always pay your fucking,
you know?
Uh,
so if you're doing,
you feel like in yourself,
like,
wow,
I'm letting myself down.
Yeah.
Once you put something up your fucking
nose,
you smack yourself in the face at that
point.
Nevermind shooting something and your
vein.
That is a complete.
Yeah.
That's the next level.
That's,
you know,
I had a friend for years that was hooked
on it.
I come into his house on Monday mornings
there'd be blood splatters on the walls
from him missing the vein she uses.
He would buy a $100 worth of heroin and
they bought coke.
He was doing the Belushi all weekend.
Oh my God.
He would Belushi it all weekend.
That speedball right.
That's like the coke and the heroin
together and it creates sort of a weird
effect.
It creates fuck getting a tornado in
your brain.
You just passed the fuck out,
you know,
this guy would be clean from Monday.
He was brilliant from Monday to Friday.
He could keep it together.
I think Thursday night he would break
down and do a little,
like a little sniff just to keep them
together during the week,
but once Friday came,
you wouldn't see him till Monday
morning.
During the week you would massage his
veins.
I got a massage.
We got to get them to go home for the
weekend and shit.
Oh my God.
And then he would switch like,
how can you go from your arm to your
toe?
I guess you half like I can't find a
vein.
Joe.
Hold on.
Let me take my shoe off and fucking
shoot my toe is just the first guy I
ever had friends that did steroids.
That was one of the most interesting
nights of my life.
We were doing coke in the middle of
everything.
He just took off his shirt and started
doing pushups.
He got up and he goes,
look at me.
What's different for you lifting?
He goes,
no.
I started doing steroids and he started
breaking it down to me.
He was getting an addiction to steroids
because he was going to every week and
just shooting and they just went off a
cycle.
Then they just stopped breaking it up.
He was on a cycle year round,
but he was addicted to the needle going
in his ass and then he would shoot it
with vitamin B and he would tell me he
can taste the vitamin B in his mouth and
shit.
I didn't fucking shoot coke.
You can taste it in your mouth.
How you really?
Yeah.
So you.
Oh,
you shoot it now shooting coke.
How much different is that supposed to
be than snorting it?
I have no idea,
but what about the people that.
I mean most pick something crazy.
Birds of a feather flock together.
I snorted.
I hung out with snow artists once they
talked to them about needles.
That's when I go home.
Once I see a needle,
I go,
I don't want to sit in a room where
there's a fucking needle because I can't
sit still.
Once I see that syringe.
You don't want me around.
I don't want to be that.
I went to cvs a month ago and they had
syringes that they give you a free
syringes.
I almost fucking died.
I don't like.
I'm empty.
I'm full.
I don't like to see them.
Those people that carry the fixes with
them,
they call them a fix kit.
Spoon and a syringe and a lighter and
the needles here.
Right.
And that when they call it the gears,
I would ask him like,
so when you go over there,
how do you shoot it?
And he goes,
we all stand around who and we.
Then we all pass the needle.
This is 82 when you could pass a veto
from one guy to the other and shoot the
ball and fucking that guy,
these kinds of
one needle to another.
Then filling it with vitamin B.
They would go,
why are we gonna?
You know,
because if,
I guess I don't know how the needle
works.
If you keep shooting,
it gets dull.
Yeah.
Just take one neat on.
But the nine guys knew each other
through each other.
Firstly you hepatitis
C,
that's the first thing he got from that
shit.
That's just that.
Now you get hepatitis C if you jam a
needle into you that's been jammed into
someone with Hepatitis C,
right?
I think so.
But you on sexual transmission also?
Correct.
Right.
He ever thought about that?
Like I've thought about that before.
Like herpes or anything
warts.
There had to be an original case like
that had to be one person that developed
this.
Like how does that develop?
I've always been curious like how the
fuck does something like a herpes,
so on point in time,
but no one has her syphilis and you blog
guy with Spanish syphilis.
It becomes the harp they can together
glide.
That's what happens.
It becomes more powerful,
worse,
you know,
like right now supposedly all these
diseases,
they disappeared for a while.
Then they make a comeback.
Something was popular last year.
We get measles.
Was it?
No,
no sexual.
Oh,
something came back last year that was
popular 10 years ago we came back.
I don't know which one it was real or
something like that.
Like I got something like I've always
had something.
You've got something right now.
I've had it for years because at night I
get itchy.
I don't know what the fuck is this.
I lay down in bed,
I get itchy as a motherfucker and when I
asked you if you have a long run and
colony of crabs just camped out and do
something.
When I took a blood test years ago,
they were like,
did you have something?
I had something and I go,
I don't know.
And they go,
you must add something because to get
the tail end I had something like when I
first moved to La,
I had something all those years on the
road,
you're going to get something now if you
don't take antibiotics,
if you get something like syphilis is
what killed Al Capone.
Right?
I'm like,
what?
What happens if like other ones like
gonorrhea,
kill you?
I don't know.
You just get better.
I know I had to guess.
I think eventually something's got to
happen through you.
Can Gonorrhea be faithful,
fatal and Kenny recover with no
medication.
Jamie,
if you just do the Wim Hof method,
which went hoff breathing,
just
just try,
try to power through the gonorrhea.
Syphilis killed you.
I'm pretty sure syphilis kills.
Like everybody that gets feed the
venereal disease,
but that's covers everything.
Couple of.
It's weird because venereal doesn't
sound like sex,
but that's what vd is.
You know,
[inaudible] a sexual transmitted
disease.
When you talking about someone having
vd.
When I was about 17,
my friend fucked his sister's best
friend and he's got something.
He got VD,
got vd and we went the next day and it
was a chick with like fucking like the
Phantom of the opera mark on her face.
Dog.
It was fucking crazy.
What was the mark on her face?
Like she.
She had like syphilis or something
started.
She
had a cut in her lip and she sucked the
fucked up
and it ran.
I never forget this.
It's not even funny.
It was really sad because I didn't know
what she had.
I just went there with my friend.
My friend goes,
you got to go in there with me,
dog.
I'm scared to walk in there.
Let's go.
What's the big deal?
They're going to give you?
Pills,
whatever.
I didn't know.
I wasn't sexually active at that age.
He was and we went in there while I was
waiting for him to go to.
This chick came into the paperwork and
she turned around and she had gotten
something that started here,
like she had like a cut or.
What's that?
When you have chapped lips or something
and all this was like half purple and
red.
She sucks.
Something bad and after that I was like,
Ooh,
I got to be careful out there.
It's a jungle.
That was the thing when we were kids,
like someone has vd.
Ah,
she's got VD.
Be careful.
He's got VD VD.
It was like,
Whoa,
you're here to here.
Betty got bed.
Oh that fucking girl got feet d,
facebook friends with me from high
school and the Pussy wouldn't get wet.
They used to call the dry Hump Affairs
Jersey.
They used to call a fairview.
The church either.
Oh,
oh
fuck.
People are so fucked up.
Girl was banging.
This girl was fucking banging though.
So you'd have to like bring vaseline or
something.
And she was from Wayne,
New Jersey,
and she was banging.
She moved to North Bergen,
like she was a sophomore and she was
dating a few guys.
Shouldn't things happen like I was
friends with.
I know she didn't like me.
She,
she just didn't like me for some reason.
I don't think the world to her either.
And one nine,
84,
I'm at a bar and this bitch comes in.
I mean banging,
banging,
banging.
They also said she had some type of Vd.
So they called the lorry Jack,
you know she's got the Jack
CDC sang a song,
she's got the Jack Jack.
Jack said he used to call her name and
Jack like,
that was like,
they just taught math at this girl and
she did like a rocky,
like a rock guy and had like long hair
and whatnot.
I saw rocky and she was banging Joe
Rogan banging and I go,
you live in North Bergen?
I,
she's like,
yeah,
I didn't go to college.
I,
I'm a,
I'm a nanny.
And she told me the guy's name and I
knew that guy.
That guy had a massage parlor years
earlier,
the guy that she was being a nanny for
and I go,
she says,
nanny,
he's just fucking.
Or something's gotta be wrong.
She looked so good in that mini skirt.
She disappeared like 1:30
and finally like three.
I'm sitting there,
I'm like,
what am I going to do tonight?
And I had like a bag of coke or go fuck
it.
I'm going to go get him.
So I went crazy.
I was.
I went to the dude's house who she's
told me I knocked on door was 3:15 in
the morning and he said,
Coco,
what are you doing?
I go,
I got to talk to Lori.
There's something missing.
He goes,
hold on,
Lori.
And she came down and she comes outside,
he's got a robe and she's got a robot.
And I looked her straight in the face.
I go,
listen,
I got like to eight balls in my pocket,
get dresses,
get the fuck out.
And she's like,
I can't.
I go,
you have to.
And we argued that for like 10 minutes.
I'm like,
I want to suck your pussy.
I want to do 30 things to you.
I don't give a fuck about the VD or the
Jack or the dry hump.
I'm on fire.
And she's like,
well,
give me 10 minutes and I know how am I
going to sneak out of there?
I Dunno.
So I waited outside for.
She's like,
I'll put Lou embed,
not run up.
About 15 minutes later I see her running
that with a purse with like a bank
deposit bag was like,
fuck him.
I can't take care of anymore.
Fuck him.
We were on foot.
It's 4:30 in the morning.
Totally Avenue.
North Bergen is a bunch of those dirty
hotels.
So on my car I got a score here.
I got co,
she's got money.
I'm going to fuck her.
I'm excited.
We go back to a hotel.
We finally registered like $30.
They asked us through one of the Jacuzzi
in the room and shit.
It was one of those dirty hotels on
tonally as you go in New York City.
We went in there,
we walk in and she goes,
rule number one,
you are not going to find me.
It's five in the morning that goes my
fucking.
That goes this night and all of a sudden
she looks at me.
She goes,
well,
if you could guess the color of my
panties,
I fuck you.
I'm like,
okay,
read.
And she goes,
they're green,
but good enough.
Started snorting coke,
eat mass.
I mean there was
five in the afternoon and Doug Flutie
was drawn.
That quarterback that
I was waking up,
she was naked,
rip apart.
I'm waking up and Doug flutie strong the
touchdown.
I got dressed and got the fuck out and
never saw her again.
Never been robbed the money.
I took everything.
She pops up on facebook about two years
ago and I'm like,
Laurie,
she's like,
fuck you,
you fat faggot and all this shit.
She's like,
you left me there that night,
but we had a good time.
Fuck yeah,
we had a good thought and I will hit her
back and go,
what color are your panties?
She goes,
what?
That's supposed to me.
That instrument in the areas I knew,
she gave me some.
She had something but I didn't give a
fuck.
It was 84 rock Hudson was died.
I didn't use a condom.
I knew the consequences.
I'm like,
fuck it.
So I knew I was going to get something
and I probably did.
I got crabs after that.
Over the holidays
I got crabs.
Yeah.
Eighty four,
85 season.
I got crabs.
I found that in the bathroom and port
authority,
the port authority to take a shit and I
pulled my pants down and I'm sitting
there reading the paper and I see a
crap.
Like I sort of sat and jump and I'm
like,
what the fuck?
And I had never heard it.
I had never heard nothing.
I went home and took my underwear off
and got
like a magnifying glass.
It was over.
It was all over me.
They were all over the couch.
I had to bring a bomb into the room,
like one of those bombs and leave for 12
hours since you really.
Oh,
I grabbed the bucket.
It was cramped up like,
oh my God,
lady next door knocked out.
Mike that I was living in.
Tenafly,
New Jersey Lady.
Next door knock.
So you have a bug problem?
I'm like,
no,
since you moved in here,
there's been crabs and
like y'all got fleas when I was in high
school and you ever have a dog with
fleas?
Fleas get into the carpet and they had
the ag act like a flea collar that you'd
put on your dog with apparently worked
and then they had these flea drops that
you put on dogs.
Fucking hated.
He would score it on there for like at
various spots like right behind the neck
and then like in the middle of the back
and the lower back and the dog would go
fucking crazy and roll around on the
ground.
Try to get that shit off them.
But if you didn't do it you,
your dog's going to get fleas.
And we had carpet does that means you
have fleas.
So when you were walking I'd like in my
bedroom,
I'd be walking in my carpet and I'd see
a flea jump onto my leg.
I'd be like fuck.
And once you have it you just have it,
you know,
like I mean there was some,
some carpet stuff that I used to have to
shake down.
So I shake down all this poison shit all
over my carpet and then you have to
vacuum it up,
but there's always one or two that
survived one or two gangster fleas.
It figured out how to fucking stay away
from the powder and then figure their
way right back onto your leg.
And it was hard to get get it off the
dogs too because then they would just go
hang out with other dogs.
They'd get it again.
Even if you cleaned him up and kill all
the fleas that got them again.
You could see the eggs,
like he would click be cleaning them.
Like your wash your dog at the base of
their hair.
You'd find the every fucking gross it
was gone.
It would just drop it and she'll over
your carpet.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah,
that's a giant issue if you have dogs
that I had a dog once that had
distemper,
caught distemper from analog.
It was so sad.
He uh,
was a puppy and he would go into
convulsions,
who'd have seizures.
He was just a little puppy,
was so sad.
We had a wind up putting them down and
um,
put them down,
man.
My veterinarian.
So good.
A guy.
This guy was,
he was crying.
He cried afterwards about how hard it
is.
I mean,
the guy just love dogs.
I love cats.
He was just so upset,
so upset.
It was really crazy,
man.
It was a weird moment that I'll never
forget.
He ended up dying in a car accident.
Drunk driver,
a drunk driver hit him,
but I never forget that.
I was like,
wow,
that guy got killed by a drunk driver.
That guy,
he didn't make any sense.
It was such a nice guy.
Boy,
did he hate marriage?
You know,
I was young.
I was 26 when I first met him,
you know,
they'd be like,
you married?
I go,
no.
He goes,
don't get married.
I'm like,
okay.
Explain to me marriage guys who have
been to hardcore divorces,
man,
they have a fucking way.
They have a way of grabbing you and
putting that urgency and you listen to
me.
Listen to me.
Don't fucking do it.
Okay?
Okay.
I won't do it.
There's nothing as bad as the divorce.
I would say death is probably worse.
Some people.
Divorce is great.
You know what the problem with a lot of
fucking people is,
especially a lot of dudes with money is
when you get married.
Your wife has my two now,
like before you got married,
you were the guy with money,
so you had a bunch of money and she's
like,
wow,
like this guy got money and then when
you get married,
guess what?
Now she's got money to now she gets her,
recognize you for you and so it's not.
You're not as cool anymore because
you're not just a guy with money.
She's got money to bitch to her fucking
money now and she's like,
God damn,
I'm going to take my share and get the
fuck outta here.
Like all of a sudden she's got your
money.
Like what happened?
What happened is like there's a bunch of
things that happen when people get
married,
right?
There's love,
there's devotion,
there's commitment,
there's a beautiful bond,
the ego you guys share,
but let's not get confused under the
exact same rules with the exact same
words.
I do,
I do.
There's a lot of scamming going on.
There's a lot of people getting robbed.
There's a lot of legal extortion.
There's a lot of legal stealing.
There's a lot of really hot women who
have no business.
Fucking some old dude.
There's a lot of really hot women that
are like fucking some guy who's 70 years
old and they talked this dummy it
marrying them with no prenuptial they
suck his dick for a couple of years and
dropped a cup them
and take a chunk.
Just take a giant chunk of millions and
millions of dollars.
That happens to.
I'm not saying it shouldn't happen and
I'm not saying it's,
it's not an interesting deal.
You know,
that some people make,
you know,
like the Guy Married Anna Nicole Smith.
Remember I used to have that bit about
that guy that was the same kind of
thing.
It was like,
nothing wrong with it.
Everybody knows what it is,
but
you can't.
That's not the same.
Like all marriages is not the same.
So people that were upset about like gay
marriage,
gay people that legitimately love each
other and they want to get married,
she'd be upset at this other shit.
She'd be upset that you could go to
vegas high on coke,
go through a drive through and get
married.
You can do that.
They're not drug testing you.
They take you to those drive through
Elvis fucking wedding chapels and Vegas.
You think they see if you're dry,
they don't give a fuck if you're drunk.
You mean maybe you can get it a note
tomorrow if you are.
I mean maybe.
I don't know.
They don't give a shit that's marriage
to.
So it's a bunch of different things to
God damn contract.
No marriage is bad for somebody when
they lose something.
That's what a basic list.
They lose a house,
they lose money if you marry somebody.
You know what I'm saying?
You go ahead.
I don't want to be married no more.
Me Either.
See the mom who's keeping the house.
It's your fucking house by.
Okay.
That's great.
Nobody.
Nobody would get angry.
Nobody would get it.
It's when you lose something,
right?
You know,
or somebody cheated on you or whatever.
I had no money when I got divorced.
It wasn't even that alone.
So you're like,
Yay.
Oh fuck you.
When I get to do comedy now the whole
thing.
But there was a kitten bowl.
Right.
And there's always fucking something.
See,
that's when marriage sucks.
I also told myself that for years and it
wasn't the marriage that sucked.
Sometimes we don't put enough into the
marriage.
You know?
I didn't know what marriage was when I
first got married.
I tell you what,
I know my marriage is now,
motherfucker.
I know what marriage is now and that's
why it works.
I know you have to put time into when I
first got married,
you do the laundry,
you cook and I give you a check and we
fuck
I fuck you when I want.
That's not mad.
When you're 25,
you think that's marriage,
you know,
you think that's marriage.
That's where I thought,
yeah,
I'll go out and work.
I didn't think you had to pay attention
or go to a date night or fucking I have
to put time into them.
Or,
you know,
I can't do a spot tonight because I'm
going to the movies with my wife.
You know,
you have to put that time and if you
want it to fucking work,
yeah,
you got to have an actual relationship.
That's where it gets tricky.
It's hard.
It's hard to find someone that you enjoy
talking to,
you know,
they enjoy being with not just doing
stuff with,
but just sitting alone and talking.
It's hard.
It's hard to find people that are on the
same wavelength as you.
It's hard to find people that want to
talk about the things you want to talk
about or want to,
you know,
want to see things from your perspective
and that you want to see things through
their perspective that you want to have
these open kind of honest conversations.
It's not easy to find someone like that.
These poor people that we all know that
are unlike dating apps,
like a,
especially smart women.
I know a lot of smart women that cannot
find a fucking man to save their life.
And you look at it,
you're like,
I don't get it.
SMART,
ambitious,
powerful woman,
hot.
Can't find a man too hard out there.
It's hard to find somebody that you sync
with that you could talk to.
I think it's way easier for a dude to
find a cool chick that is for a girl to
find a guy who's got his shit together.
Maybe I'm just guessing,
but I think it's probably harder.
I felt a lot of single women out there
to fucking good looking at jobs and
shit,
but we don't.
We also know him like that too.
It runs two ways.
Joe.
We didn't get that close to them that we
didn't see what the
idiosyncrasies works.
Even with us,
there's a bunch of women that look at
you and God love to be with them.
Then they get with this
guy flies out of town every fucking
weekend.
I can't be.
You know what I'm saying?
Like little things that they don't
understand.
Am I coming?
No.
He ever had guys that you're friends
with who like back up off the comedy
because they got a new girlfriend and
the new girlfriend's like,
I don't want you going out.
You know,
I don't want you doing sets every night.
You don't have to do them every night
like,
but I do,
if I want to get better,
like that's like,
you know how like baseball players to go
to the field and practice?
Yeah.
I have to go on stage.
It's the same thing.
You don't think about it that way
because you don't do it,
but you got to understand it's the same
thing.
Well,
when I did it,
the stripper,
the crazy bitch,
she doesn't understand that.
She was awesome by the way.
No,
she was,
she was you and her together with one of
my favorite couples of all time.
She still retarded.
I loved a boyfriend,
a picture of her boyfriend.
Now he's got cockeyed.
I mean she's a fucking nut.
She's a fucking knows.
One of the reasons why I fell in love
with.
She's a millionaire,
you know,
she's a fucking gazillionaire.
He,
these fucking dudes get all the money
again.
Sheet or at first when we broke up,
she went to Florida and she ended up
marrying this old Hindu guy.
There you go.
Like he was 76.
They lasted three months.
He died when I was at.
What was I saying?
Left her.
His money.
There you go.
She took the money and invested in Jim's
curves.
Bought one,
bought two or three,
but four became like a fucking a mogul
and then sold them all when they were
still hot.
Wow.
They went out of business.
Curves.
Went out of business.
I think something,
something.
I don't know.
They're not as popular as they were
anymore here.
The whole idea was like,
don't work out that hard.
I can keep it curves.
Just come on in.
Well,
I thought it was a place just for
everyone's willing to ambitious just for
women.
I didn't know it was just kidding.
Oh,
okay.
But yeah,
it is just a place for women,
but you know,
you hear like curves,
you think of it as,
you know when you say embrace your
curves.
Yeah,
definitely.
For sure.
What are you trying to know?
What are you really saying?
Are you saying embrace your curves?
You saying you know,
don't work out that hard.
What are you saying?
Don't bother getting fit.
I don't know.
What you're saying,
you can't go there.
You can't work out there.
No,
but you can.
You can never have a men.
Only Jim know if you had a men only gym,
it will be empty.
Well,
wouldn't.
It wouldn't even matter.
Like women would protest appellee's
fucking humps go to the gym to see girls
anyway.
Most of them,
most of them do,
so that's why it would be empty.
There's a lot of guys go to the gym and
they don't even get motivated unless
girls working out there,
don't look at them.
Look at them.
Monday,
workout yoga pants.
Very primal.
You know you're like naked,
but covered up with like cloth,
like paint,
paint cloths,
that little monkey sweating like yoga
pants.
You're feeling like trump grabbed that
fucking monster.
I was with my friend Cameron Hanes in
Boston.
We're working out at this gym and there
was this girl that was,
you know those hardcore gym girls.
His hardcore gym girls who just go,
I follow a couple of them on instagram
and they do squats and fucking they're
doing like what a perfect example is
that guy carrying who is here carrying
fitsgibbons.
His wife's name is Jack Jessica.
She's a crossfit champion and she's just
ridiculously fit.
Just ridiculously fit,
but those kinds of like gym girls,
don't.
They scare the fuck out of you?
A little bit.
Little crazy.
I don't say nothing to him.
I just walked right past them.
There's a girl,
but why that doesn't?
That lists the whole fucking thing.
She's crazy.
She's fucking brutal.
Mean campaigns.
We're looking at her and Kim's like,
I want to be built like her.
I wish I had her build.
She was jacked.
This lady was just doing squats and
shit.
Fucking powder on her hands and shit.
Big Ass
dead lifts,
so women just embraced that.
They love it.
Now if they were told they can't go to a
gym because it's an all male power
lifting gym,
but the problem is like a girl goes to a
gym and hits on guys.
It's really not that big of a deal,
but if a guy goes to an all girl,
gems starts hitting on the girls,
that becomes a.
That becomes gross.
That's becomes harassment.
Like he can't.
You can't work out just a different
feeling.
It's a different feeling for them to hit
on us than it is for us to hit on.
That just know is not the same kind of
danger.
You know,
a guy hitting on a girl.
There's a certain element of danger
involved in that.
Right?
The girl,
like if some crazy girl comes to the
gym,
she's like,
Hey,
I found a fucking give you a dead lift.
You know what I mean?
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't feel threatened.
Like,
get Outta here.
Crazy
to lose you.
But,
but like if you go to crunch those
Hollywood gyms and all those,
you see that the girls get ready an hour
before they go to the gym,
make up the hat with the tail coming
out.
They're color coordinated.
I mean,
they go to those gyms to get picked up
and the guys that go there,
they go for action to when you go to the
y,
it's slows down a little bit.
Let's do a couple of women that go in
there.
They gotta stab and I see him all the
time.
They go in there with the little towels
and the yoga pants and then mingling
with the trainers and shit,
but then you go to other gyms.
That's not even happening.
It's just certain gyms called for that.
You also recognize what a person's got
going on physically.
You see some girls in one of them,
those things,
she got that,
but bob machine,
you know that one,
like they're sending out pheromones and
shit and they're showing you their
shape.
You know they got yoga pants on or
shorts.
Shorts are risky,
especially when you're doing them kinda
kicking maneuvers.
There was any sort of opening there and
some things get pushed aside or come
flying out of the bottom of there yet.
Be careful.
It's a move,
but you're.
You're seeing them exert.
You've seen them work hard.
Seeing them show their vitality.
You know on the lift in that
there's always like some dude helping
them come up.
One more,
one more,
but she's not just doing that for him.
She's doing that for other guys too.
She's like putting out that sent.
Accelerating the game.
The whole competition just ramps up a
couple of notches while she's doing
squats.
Ass Out,
ridiculous squats,
deep
clink,
high five.
The guys walks around,
makes eye contact with the audience.
See who's checking around hard.
There was a girl at the y when I first
started going on one in Hollywood,
Spanish girl,
torture,
torture.
She wouldn't shave her armpits flow and
the sweat would drip from her armpit.
And here's where it gets better.
She would always wait gray sweatpants
and she wouldn't wear underwear.
So you can see the sweat from a monkey
come right through the fucking.
So she walked up to see the fucking wet
thing.
Egg right toes.
She didn't give a fuck.
She was hot as fuck.
You know,
I'm an old man.
I've been talked to a black car and that
talking to the different guys,
but she'd be benching and she opened up
her thighs and that little swamp just be
fucking drenched with sweat.
It was tremendous.
I would look at it and shake my fuck.
This girl's,
you know,
Hollywood man.
That's what happened.
Let's start with the Hollywood.
Yesterday morning I had to be that
lunchtime and I'm driving and I see a
black dude that wade,
he was six feet with 120 pounds,
that skinny with Clint Eastwood hat on
from a fistful of dollars and the Poncho
from clothing and he was standing next
to a big,
fat white dude with a beard like Jesus
with sandals and the Jesus thing.
And I said to myself,
dog,
I'm in Hollywood.
This is it.
It's fucking.
This is what I'm going to say.
You know,
you see that at the comedy store almost
Sunday night,
Sunday night.
You see that one dude dresses like
Jesus.
Yeah,
he no explanation.
One time he came by and he wasn't
dressed like Jesus.
I was disappointed.
I seen that guy 100 times at least
dressed like Jesus,
and then one time I saw him,
he wasn't dressed like Jesus.
So I was like,
what the fuck are you doing here,
man?
Like once you commit to that outfit.
Right.
Have you ever seen him without the Jesus
outfit once?
Yeah.
He said he walks in Jesus to his head
down like that folder from the back.
And He.
It's interesting.
I mean he found something.
He found his niche.
I guess they used to be at duty.
You remember the guy who used to walk up
and down the street with a cross on his
back?
A bunch of people behind them.
Yeah.
There was a dude who used to walk down
the street with a cross and sometimes
people would carry the cross and
sometimes he would strap it on his back,
but he would walk down with a bunch of
disciples.
They all had bibles and they would start
like yelling out different,
uh,
different quotes from the Bible and they
would,
uh,
tell them to people in the front patio.
This is back before the front patio had
a bar.
Remember the front patio was basically
wasted space until the new
administration came along and when did
they open up the bar at the front patio?
I don't know how many years ago before I
came back,
but now it's a vibrant little foggy.
It was always something,
man,
he had it.
Princess Corey had it,
but she opened the just so she could
drink.
That's it.
I mean she used to open.
She was walking away.
People be like,
what is the bartender?
You know,
it was never really.
They,
it would sell like nine beers or
something.
Now it's a fucking bar.
Like you said.
Do you know they used to do shows.
There were on the back patio.
They had a standup show there.
They would set up a mic out there when
they did it a couple of years ago
apparently.
But the neighbors complained before we
came back.
They,
they were,
they would have like an open mic night.
They would have a spill out show where
they would have an open mic night out
there on the patio,
but apparently someone,
people just yelling at God or something.
You know what I mean?
The yelling,
the microphone.
That's such a fucking,
you know,
I was watching almost famous the other
day.
You ever watch that movie?
Almost famous.
I was whatever.
I was watching it and they got to the
part when they were at the hotel next
door and they actually,
you see them crossing the street in the
store.
The lights are blinking at the store.
It's supposed to be 19,
69.
What are you gonna do with the store?
Fucking put a board over it.
But that was the hotel like that was a
hot hotel.
When the store went from Ciro's to the
store,
was it closed down for awhile?
I'm not sure
because the store is,
was opening the seventies,
right?
I want to say 74 or something.
Is that right?
Seventy two.
Seventy four.
So that.
But what,
but Ciro's was in like the Bugsy Siegel
days,
which was what wasn't that like the 19
thirties or something?
No,
twenties.
When was the Bugsy Siegel?
Maybe the fifties.
Yeah,
it must be right.
Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis.
Right.
It was sears as closed in 1957.
And then it was a rock club,
rock and roll club in the 19 sixties.
Wow.
What was that called?
Uh,
just added another page.
It's the best spot in Hollywood.
It doesn't say what it was called,
but it was.
You were just saying that you were
talking one day and you said that that
must be like a beam that shoots down to
put all those people together at the
comedy store.
Where if we look at that fucking almost
famous.
I mean everybody stayed at that hotel
next door.
That was a spot where you just checked
in when you weren't on tour.
We're not on tour this year.
What do you want to do?
Let's go to the riot house and get
fucked up for a week and a half.
Yeah.
It's amazing how those two spots and
next to each other like this.
So legendary.
And then next to each other.
I'd like to get some sort of fucking
native
American medicine man to walk around
that place.
Tell me what kind of spirits he senses.
Just 200 years.
Two Hundred Years of comedy,
of uh,
the of murders,
the Bugsy Siegel days,
like how many people were whacked in
that spot?
The rock days.
How many people?
Probably odd of a rock club and the 19
sixties and seventies before it became
the store.
How much craziness went on there and you
believe February 19th.
On my birthday I'll be at the store 20
fucking years.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Twenty years.
That place was in my life.
Like usually you hang out at the bar,
your neighborhood go for like four
years.
Then you graduate,
you're done.
You know those bars that you all trickle
down a bug visa,
whatever the fuck.
I've been going to the store for 20
years.
Second time I got on state,
somebody came up to me and said,
there's Mitzi shore seeing you yet.
Like I was always destined for the
school.
Like I knew it.
I knew it.
Like I just know it.
And then the more I got into comedy,
over the years people would say to me,
there's Mitzi scene he had.
She likes characters or whatever.
But it's so weird.
I had been there for 20 fucking years.
I.
We were talking the other day about how
she used to call you fat baby.
That was your name on the line.
I'm a fat baby.
Oh,
it's my navy and she would stick a
finger in my stomach and go,
still let the era.
That's how cool.
Mr Joe always my fat babysit over here
next to me.
Fat Baby.
Let me see your stomach.
Let me rub it.
And then she would put the pin in it.
Twenty fucking years.
I went home the other night.
I had scratched my head a few times,
like 20 years.
I've been doing this kind of a shift.
The 25 fucking years.
First Time I got on stage that I fucking
think I'd be here 25 years later I think
I started don't,
I didn't think anything.
I just thought a finally I'm going to be
able to do something with my life.
Like that's all I wanted to do.
Just something with my life,
you know,
talking to my buddy because ever since I
shot the special,
been thinking about 90,
19,
93 a lot.
Like how well I was 1993.
It was living in New York City.
Why 90?
Three specific.
That's when I made my transition.
That's when I did comedy for two years.
The way I went to Jujitsu for two years,
it was very erratic.
I would go twice one week,
one week I wouldn't go.
Then I go three times one week and then
I would go for two weeks.
It was very erratic.
I didn't know how to really get my hands
on it,
but in 1993 I went to the city.
I was just.
I was broken from the divorce at nothing
going on.
I was broke.
I went home and lived with a friend of
mine and just went around the city and
did calm me and I had no,
I had no comprehension and what I was
doing.
And then one night I walked into your
old triple in.
Used to be like an open mic that started
at 11 and went till two or 3:00 and I
went in there one night about.
I just finished driving a limo and I
dropped the guy off in Manhattan and I
go,
let me go get a spot over that,
and I went over there and they said,
there's no spots tonight because
Leguizamo is on stage and he was
working.
One of those one man shows this place
was a fucking dive.
Like every time I'd walk in there I
think about my comedy career.
I got to figure something out because
I'm not going to keep doing this
display.
Smelled like cigarette smoke.
There were seven people in New Orleans.
You know what I'm saying?
When you first started do Konami you're
waiting for the lights and
the CBS to be there and shit.
CBS Ain't going to be here.
Why do I keep coming back here?
And finally one night I went there,
I saw like it was dominant one.
Then I go,
I get it,
I get it.
I thought it was too special.
I'd have to do that,
you know?
Sorry,
I officially.
I'm one of those fucking things.
We got a piece of bone.
Something you gotta you gotTa make me
cough.
Sorry.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A leg was almost onstage.
It was a dive and it really.
I didn't know.
I didn't know anything about comedy.
I had read the Judy Carter Book.
I had read a couple books by that
fucking writer that when that real
solutia ball,
three Belzer's book,
who Richard Belzer know wrote a book on
stand up comedy.
I read the book by Lenny Bruce.
Ladies and gentlemen.
We live at the Chelsea hotel and he
fucking did heroin at night with jazz
musicians.
Oh yeah.
That's a great.
Put me over the top,
but I taught standing up or something
that you became.
I didn't know you had to work on it.
That's what I'm trying to say to you.
I thought that when people went up on
stage shoot a special like Joe Rogan
Shit.
Tell Him we got cameras really?
Alright,
cool.
Tell him to go on state.
I thought when you shot a special,
you just went up and talked for 30
minutes.
I didn't know there was any preparation.
I didn't really have
anything to go by.
I went in there and I understand the
process now.
I think three,
not even like a month later I was back
in Colorado and I was determined to get
onstage every night.
This was what I was going to do.
This is what I'm going for,
this is how I'm going to do it,
you know,
these are the clubs I'm going to work.
I had no,
no idea what the fuck was.
I would just go on stage loosely.
I would write whatever I could and just
go on stage loosely.
I never knew that you build from that.
I didn't know these things,
so I keep thinking about 93.
I lived in a fucking room with my buddy
who did heroin.
I had one white shirt.
I would sell cars on 11th avenue down
there,
you know,
New York City.
I had one white shirt and I would wear
the same shirt everyday.
I would have to come home,
jump in the shower,
and I would wash my shirt in the shower
and I would hang it up and then I would
iron it every fucking day.
You know?
I was just a struggling open Miker,
you know,
I was driving a limo some days,
some days I would sell cars,
some days I would pass out packages for
att and t and get $400 a week.
I was just putting it together,
man,
you know,
and it was,
it just seemed
so interesting.
Like I just,
I didn't,
I had no illusions of grandeur bro.
I just wanted to do something with my
life.
There was no,
I wasn't going to be Kevin Hart or
fucking bill cosby and nothing.
I just want to do something,
you know.
So this is why I keep thinking about how
fucking Tony,
three years later I shot a special and
just,
it just goes back to what you did.
You know,
I had one,
I would have to,
I wouldn't have to be at work till 10
some days,
but I would take the 6:00 AM bus because
if I take the 6:00 AM bus,
my friend with the steroids,
his father was a bus driver.
He let me right to the city for free.
So I would take the 6:00 AM bus so I
could save those $3.
That's how fucking poor I was.
And then to get home I would fucking go
into service when I would sell cars and
we go into the service at 9:00 and I
would still change when people's cards
until I got home.
I would bring just enough money for
lunch between rent,
child support,
close reefer cocaine and fucking.
I wasn't even doing a lot of coke then
if my buddies and I will have to do it
because I was just trying to do comedy,
you know?
And you think about the beginning,
what you really went through,
how you were,
you delivered papers,
write papers or whatever and to see you
now.
It's such a big difference.
But I never saw this.
I never saw the tail end of this.
I just wanted to do something.
You know?
Yeah.
When you see someone that's already
doing comedy clubs and headlining places
and you're just starting now,
it doesn't seem that far away.
It's like,
oh,
I need to do is just get an act together
and I can do what he's doing.
How come I can't do it and you think you
can and then it takes years.
Like somebody tried to tell me once that
it took 10 years for you to become a
real headline or my dad's crazy
headliner in two years,
get out of here,
but it really does.
It really does because there's
something.
Something happens 10 years in or maybe
you're smarter than me.
Maybe it'll only take you a couple.
But for me it was like 10 years and I
get a better understanding what the fuck
I'm doing.
I'm like,
Oh,
I kinda get it now.
I kind of get it now,
but you still don't see it the way you
would see it if it wasn't you.
If you know as much as you know about
standup and you could watch yourself not
be you,
you would be able to fix a lot of things
with your act.
But a lot of the things with your act
like you kind of shield yourself because
you're just trying to get it to work.
Just trying to put it together,
you know,
and a lot of times you're not even aware
of,
uh,
how the joke is coming off to other
people because you're doing it yourself.
You're too caught up in the idea of
delivering it to understand what it's
like to receive it.
And that takes a long fucking time to
figure it out.
And still to this day,
I fuck it up to those day,
especially when I'm working on new bits
because you got to take these weird
chances with new bits.
You got to like start premises maybe
that you don't know where they're going
and let,
let it,
let it under pressure of stage sometimes
come out.
You know,
especially when you're working out at
the store trying to come up with new
stuff under the pressure of being
onstage.
You can sort of like every now and then
pop an idea through every now and then a
new tagline comes through that makes you
laugh and a new moment comes through.
And if you don't invest in those moments
of doing those,
those bits on stage,
you never fucking know.
And if you don't take those chances,
if you just keep doing the same shit
over and over again,
you don't take those chances,
you don't.
You don't know whether or not you could
go down those roads,
go ahead and become a headline until 18
years.
That's when I felt comfortable.
Headline.
That's crazy.
I had 40 minutes to six years,
45 minutes.
I love when guys look at you and go,
well,
I got a bowel.
The big difference in being a fucking
headline in my friend.
Okay.
This weekend there's a great fight on
the card.
It's surgery.
It's Pedis Pedis against Anthony Pettis
Holloway.
Right?
So you look at Max Holloway's in his
nine,
zero fucking hits hard.
Heart of a lion,
crazy pet has had something called
experience.
He's been in there with Benson and he's
been in there with some big fucking
names.
He's been then championship fights when
the lights matter and shit like that.
That's called experience.
That experience is so fucking crucial.
That experience is so crucial at the
store.
I am very proud to be a store comic
because of all those years of doing
those weights bites.
So you,
I get myself out of any situation,
I get myself out of it and he situation.
When you're a plumber,
when you're,
uh,
when you're a Roofer,
okay day,
your job is the same.
You're gonna fucking roof.
Why you're paying me 25 instead of 15 is
because I know how to get around the
problems.
When you come to me and go boss the
fucking pipe there.
I got a flashlight and stop.
There's a piece of cake.
I just build a box around you follow me.
It's the same thing with comedy.
Like it.
I knew I could do an hour,
but I always felt like that pennzoil
commercial.
You could either pay me now or you can
pay me later.
I love those motherfuckers to come out
here and go,
bitch,
I been,
I was a headline at four years.
I'm a regular at the store.
You know what?
They're going to get it at the store one
night.
They're going to get it,
they're going to get it.
They're going to have to follow somebody
who they're not ready for.
And it's not because they've only been
doing comedy six years.
It's going to hurt them a little more
than it would hurt me.
And you talk.
I know there's a 50 slash 50 shot
everyday.
I write jokes.
I prepare them.
I know I'm going to go up there and do
the best I can,
but sometimes that don't pay that and
sometimes there's a girl in there before
you attended a great night every other
night.
She's bombed tonight.
She blows up that place and you got to
go up there and figure a way around it.
That's an experience.
Fucks you up.
That's when I could.
You could blow up that room and I'll
tell you what,
I may not be able to follow you,
but I'll get a few labs with.
Ten years ago I wasn't getting anything
because I was caught up in the lights
and let's keep it going for joe or more
time.
It's really funny and not use that word,
but if you go up there and just run with
that energy,
it's experience in my world.
You know,
I didn't make any big decisions so I got
fucking.
I could feel the difference on state
now.
Twenty five years.
You could do anything.
You John Jacques Machado.
You Ever See John Jack Rowe?
He talks to you.
He talks to Joe and rolls with me,
Eh,
not silly phone.
God,
whatever.
He doesn't even know because he's been
doing it for 20 years and I just saw a
guy,
a guy did that.
Marcello Garcia died,
then a seminar and he was for years.
I just put myself in the half guard.
He goes,
I could feel anything you got to do.
even when you're going to pop that leg
over to get away.
He goes,
I'll just catch you with this leg and
put you now.
I got your neck.
It's amazing.
I go,
how'd you get that?
Good.
He goes,
I put myself in half guard every fucking
day for 10 years.
I know exactly what reaction you're
going to do.
It's called experience when you got.
I never had the hard times.
I have had at the comedy store,
when you're dying at a club and it's a
feature headliner Mc club,
you have momentum to pick yourself back
up.
So if I go over there and pick up die
for 10 minutes,
I could get onto something and gradually
work them back at the store.
You don't have that grace.
You have 15 fucking minutes and once you
die at the store for seven minutes,
it's like the fucking Roman colosseum.
You run them with.
That ain't no getting back into the
store to store.
I've never had a medium set up the
store.
I either do great or I fucking die.
I die most of the time.
But if you know what I'm saying here,
I'm in the store.
There's no coming back.
You don't have 20 minutes of work itself
out of the situation.
They also know there's a bunch of people
coming.
Next comes next.
Who's next?
What else?
We got to see,
you know,
and sometimes you'll see someone that's
just there just on a normal night.
Maybe their ideas would work,
but tonight it's not going to work
because it's just been too many
different people on before them.
And then it's just I've seen too much,
you know?
Then that's one of those things where
those late night spots are so important.
I wonder if that exists in music too.
I wonder if in music it helps the
performers,
if they get occasionally a real small
crowd,
they have to sing for a crowd of 15,
20 people,
you know.
I wonder if that lets you get in your
own head better,
you know,
but we can point on lives,
especially those first six years of the
comedy store,
1245,
you've got to assume there's going to be
17 people in the audience if you're
lucky,
if you're lucky and you have to say
something that they haven't heard.
If they sat there all fucking night,
they've heard everything.
They've heard everything topical and it
would force you to go out of your realm.
I love it.
You know when we shot,
we were telling them about specials,
shooting specials.
When I shot the first show,
I died because I was too worried about
my material.
I really bought into Jerry Seinfeld.
Then I remembered what the fuck I am the
second show,
and you just now you get it back.
Yeah.
There's so many different focuses is 25
years.
You shoot a special and you still
fucking up come.
Yeah,
a dog.
This is why I love this because I
learned something new every fucking day.
It's definitely.
Well,
as long as you have new subjects to talk
about,
you're going to have new ideas,
so you're going to have new bits.
So you're going to have work to do.
They're not going to be done.
They're not done right away.
You got to go over them.
You got to listen to recordings.
So there's a lot lot going on.
It's,
it's,
it's weird in that like if you go to see
the rolling stones,
you want to hear it brown sugar,
you know you,
you want to hear a sympathy for the
devil.
If I go to see you,
I want to hear some new shit.
Now.
It's just the way it is for our
business,
but it's also so exciting.
You know?
I mean,
it's such a fun fucking thing to do.
Well,
there's two.
There's two trains of thought to this
that are really interesting because I
did something this year that I knew I
couldn't pull off like there's no way,
but for me,
I could only shoot a special every 18
months.
My next special is no.
Once I looked at the product and the
special,
I knew that those jokes could have still
had six more months of work and you
follow me.
That's the problem.
We have to.
There's a joke.
I closed it,
but I've been doing it now for two years
just because people say,
I came to seeing you and do that fucking
job and I've noticed how good that joke
is become,
and every two weeks I had a tag for that
joke even though it's still fucking old
when I do it.
This is exactly what Tom Papa said on
Monday.
Exact same thing.
It bothers me to no end.
You know,
I put a CD out a couple years ago and I
liked the bit I did,
but that bit was not finished.
I didn't know at the time.
Right.
It's ready,
fuck no.
I've added 10 minutes for that bit in
the last fucking year,
just because I liked it so much.
There's something in there.
Yeah.
What the fuck did I do?
I just let it go.
So as a trainer thought that,
and I didn't know this.
Listen me,
when I come to see you every year,
I want you to have 30 minutes of
material.
Something had to happen in your life.
Yeah.
What you're telling me is you can make
that joke better.
Run it by me.
Let's see what else you added.
Let's see what else you added to it.
So.
And that's what I'm going to continue to
do now.
Those jokes that I had from the special
guests,
what I'll put them away now,
but I'll bring them back in a year and
how at different tags and even if every
time you do a long set,
just bring one bit back down to six and
do it.
They don't.
They're going to strengthen.
Mm.
And one day you're going to be able to
do three hours.
I don't,
I don't fucking know,
but I'm just saying it's nice those bits
and never done.
That's a mistake I made on the first two
albums,
those bits and never done,
but they're done sometimes.
Right?
Sometimes you get to them when you're
like,
I don't even want to do this anymore.
Oh No,
you're.
When you're done,
you're done.
That's why I didn't call for responses.
We know that I'm building.
I went to Portland last week.
I'm done.
He just started to take some time off.
You need to recharge.
Recharge.
Yeah.
Right.
You need to do come on thing.
You need to get a.
sometimes when you do too much county in
a row,
you go to stuff.
I want to deprogram myself,
you know,
special.
I didn't want to keep saying I'm coming
on the feet.
I didn't want to keep.
I didn't want to keep doing the jute
that.
So I stopped deprogram yourself.
You've got to break those bad habits to
break that habit.
The only way to break that habit,
just to forget about it.
Right.
At least when it comes to comedy,
you know,
I want to forget about it and I won't do
it no more.
I had a lot of promotion that shit.
This week I podcast you,
I had a ton of shit.
It's Christmas.
I got to take it to the zoo at night for
the fucking lights,
so I said this is a great week to do it,
but I've learned a lot man from shooting
this that no specials ever done.
That's why we want to hear if you go see
the stones,
you might be disappointed sometimes
because sometimes the stones to play a
song,
it doesn't sound like what you're used
to listening to it because over the
years they added this fucking whole
thing on the road to it,
which you'll never hear because you
didn't go,
you know?
Yeah.
You definitely get hear that.
Sometimes when people do live versions
or something,
they put a whole new twist to it.
Like that band,
honey,
they do that all the time.
They'll do a song and it's like it's a
different version of a song that I've
heard on their CD.
I think going to see live bands is good
for us to excellent for us.
First of all,
let's be honest.
You know when your dad was.
I was watching something.
What was that?
Oh,
I was watching a video of Johnny Cash.
It's A.
Okay.
And I had to ask myself this question.
I go,
Joe does as a comedian.
You're going to fucking tell me that a
little bit of Johnny cash isn't me.
That's how I wanted it.
I wanted Johnny cash.
I want a little bit of the allman
brothers that guarantee.
I want you to know that this could get
dirty quick.
Yeah,
we.
This could be quick.
This can be zero to 100 quick and this
motherfucker I want a little lennon skin
and in my comedy,
that singer,
the way he looks at you and shit,
it's just the sad.
A Spanish all my copy.
Know my comedy has Julia serving in it.
My comedy has Richard Pryor.
You've got lenny bruce in it.
Any bad.
I liked the fucking thunder.
Have led Zepplin that done.
There were lab you watch led Zepplin
from the garden.
There's no fucking lights or explosions.
Were midgets running around?
It's just for dirty white motherfuckers
and I liked the fucking lead sapling
effect in my standup.
It all mixes in there,
but Johnny cash is definitely my standup
for sure.
Definitely that shit.
Definitely everything you've ever seen
that's made you feel good.
Gets in absolutely absolute fucking.
Everything.
Movies,
everything.
How much do you know about Rodney
Dangerfield?
Half and half.
We're trying to figure out when what
the.
There's a bunch of different stories of
the no respect,
like when it changed it to no respect.
Someone was telling me it was from a
fucking movie at a movie came out and
then after that movie he just started
saying,
no respect,
no respect at all.
That guy was awesome.
I'm so glad I got to meet him.
I got to meet him.
Apparently he was still doing coke,
who's like seven years old,
who's hanging out with this 40 year old
hot,
broad,
having a great time,
which I got a call to go to a fucking
audition one day and I go,
what am I reading for Lego?
You're reading from the new Rodney
movie.
I go down to the sunset right by the
Tequila hut down before we hit the
comedy store.
There's that little tequila at that
light there.
[inaudible] 50 feet and I went in there
and I walked in the room and who's in
the room have Rodney dangerfield though?
This is the motherfuck.
I weighed the ear for the see easy money
because in my world,
easy money is fucking tremendous.
I went to the.
I went live.
I don't drink.
You just said it yourself.
Joey,
don't drink.
I took an eight pack of Budweiser neps
to see fucking easy money.
Okay.
Budweiser nip the smaller ones,
cracking the things and flicking it.
I was having a good time,
but Rodney.
Okay.
I walked into this room and his Rodney
Dangerfield,
I'm going to read for Rodney
Dangerfield.
I get the things.
I want you to sit here.
You know,
whatever.
I didn't overly au Jus the reason why he
hasn't seen all that shit.
I just read Bro.
And he goes,
listen,
I really like your read the road.
You're the role you read for is already
cast,
but do me a favor.
Just show up.
You didn't know that Joe.
So he goes,
just show up.
He called the house.
My wife answered.
She was dating me.
She goes,
you know Rodney call day before,
like,
what do you say?
She goes to go to Hollywood studios
tomorrow at eight in the morning.
I go to that.
I get the road.
He didn't say,
I called my agent.
My leg goes,
now he's going to find something for
you.
Just show up.
That's how much he dug me.
Seven days.
I worked on this movie though.
It's the worst movie of all time.
Only comedy central as it once a year.
Like at four in the morning.
It's called back by midnight.
I play Joe.
Joe backed by them were all in prison,
were all in prison.
And uh,
we,
we figured out that we break out at
night and go steal the hardware store
supplies and we fucking got lounges.
Jacuzzis at the prison now everyday I
wouldn't have to go in and they sign up.
They go,
no,
you got to go see Rodney.
So I have to walk into Rodney's trailer.
Knock on the door.
He danced with fucking the robot naked
commodity sign and he got,
I see you tomorrow night.
And that was my job seven fucking days,
Bro.
He was old.
He couldn't remember his lines.
They had to read them the lines off
camera and then he would say the lines
over again.
But for me it meant the world man.
That's Rodney Dangerfield,
man.
That's huge.
Yeah.
He's.
I mean,
when you think about all time
influential figures with his Rodney
dangerfield specials,
he introduced the world to some of the
greatest of all time.
Great.
Greatest.
And not a lot
of people will ever do something like
that.
Yeah.
A lot of comedians would never do.
Have you ever heard some of the
backstories to the.
To the HBO specials?
Yeah.
No,
no.
To the Rodney.
Things like how he got into it with.
He got into it with the.
What's his name?
[inaudible] at dice wears leather
jackets.
Barry Sobel.
You know,
he stuck up for comics,
right?
I could be.
I hate working at clubs where it's a
comedy,
a comic on club,
and they treat you like a dick.
You ain't some fucking do from Missouri.
You're a comic.
How can you treat me like this?
Like he really fought for comics.
You know,
and there was one story where barry
sober wanting to wear a leather jacket,
I kept arguing with him and he goes,
dog,
you know,
dice West Eleventh,
knock it the fuck off.
Go get a sweater.
That would suck though if your battery.
So when you wear a leather jacket all
the time,
I think he ended up wearing the leather
and the special.
I don't know if he did.
Didn't he have like a members only
jacket made out of leather?
Something something.
Uh,
just just amazing when you're around
those people.
You know,
when that was around Rodney that week,
it was just fucking great though.
Paul Rodriguez kept on doing an
impersonation of him.
He goes,
go ahead and do another impersonation of
the fight.
And you replaced it with George Lopez.
Say Shit the rest of the week.
Rodney wasn't fucking around.
He was still smoking dope.
He was still smoking dope all day.
Walk around the set with a joint in his
hand.
You gotTa love it.
Wow.
Did you ever see when he was going on
stage with a bathrobe on?
No.
He did a lot of shows where he was naked
with a bathrobe on and go on stage with
fucking slippers.
He would slide up to this stage,
just fucking walk up to the microphone
and do his entire hour with a fucking
bathrobe on with nothing underneath.
I was working as a security guard at
great woods in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
Great Woods.
Like the concert place is an outside
amphitheater and you know,
a covering of some part of the areas
covered in the back area is exposed as
the lawn.
And Rodney played there,
you know,
it's a big fucking place.
Like Bon Jovi played there.
I saw bill cosby there.
I saw Kennison there.
And uh,
Rodney,
I didn't say a fucking man.
Bill cosby's.
I wasn't paying attention to him.
He was there and I didn't watch like I
saw him there.
He was there.
I barely paid attention.
I just,
I wasn't into what he was like.
I thought of him as like a clean
comedian.
That was 19,
you know,
I was too crazy,
but I'm.
Rodney was in the back and one of the
guys who works for us,
because dude,
he goes,
Rodney's back there as dick and his
balls are hanging out,
I guess fucking bag.
He doesn't give a shit.
I don't give a fuck.
He doesn't give a fuck.
I always got no pants on.
He's got nothing on and I saw him
walking around with a bathrobe.
I've remember seen it like remember,
like looking down this hall towards the
back area where the backstages and I'm
seeing Rodney greenroom and he's
walking around was bathrobe.
I'm like,
that is fucking amazing.
He would go on stage.
I remember him going onstage.
I remember him killing too.
Yeah,
we loved him.
He was an old man.
I didn't give a fuck.
I'm not to interrupt you.
The other day I saw a thing on.
Somebody posted this.
It was Frank Sinatra on the tonight show
and Don rickles Kaimana.
Oh yeah,
I did.
You torture him.
Todd ruckle's is amazing.
You see,
if you find johnny years from John,
first off,
so not just so bad as tremendous.
Listen,
man,
that dude.
I watched those two things.
The Hbo bottom and I fell in love with
them.
I don't care about all those behavior
problems I watched that meant as a bad
mother fucker dog.
What behavior problems did he have?
I don't know.
Like he just fucking put up with this
gentle shit.
Look at.
Watch this.
Watch this show.
Really crank this up.
Make this look good with his boots out
and shit.
You got boots?
Look at him.
Pull the audio from Youtube.
Can they hear the audio?
No.
The people can't.
Oh,
give them a little audio.
The audio recording can do youtube
can't.
Why can't they?
Johnny Carson.
This would definitely get pulled from
youtube.
Alright folks.
Unfortunately you're going to have to.
If you watch this on youtube,
you'll have to listen to the audio
version of.
It's called a.
what's the name of it?
Johnny Carson show
was this.
How old do you think Johnny was here?
What's this chart?
Both of them got to be 60
this face.
This is the animal
he will ask
when he takes his hand,
the way it drops down on his knees,
he's kissing the king's hall.
The Sinatra this know.
Maybe say he's got the wig.
It's a light wig.
He never went to crazy with the wig.
He never went full.
Burt Reynolds.
There's no one here in this.
Unfortunately.
They can't hear this on youtube right
now.
What's that?
The audio recording here.
Yeah,
but the people on Youtube that are
watching and we'll watch in the future
can hear it.
Right.
Let's not do that.
It makes her.
Makes her goofy thing,
but no one is watching these guys.
He's touring still,
you know?
Yeah.
He's 90.
He's young.
Don rickles is down at the Canyon club
when it was soon.
He's called the Canyon Club with a.
what's his face?
Regis.
Let's go.
Yeah,
find out what the club?
Yes.
Regis and Don rickles a touring
together.
They have a little act.
Fuck yeah.
I'm going to that shit.
Fuck.
That is Kinda hope it doesn't pass
already.
Goddammit.
Did it pass already?
They have a billboard on the one on one.
If you're coming back from thousand
oaks,
he could see it on the one on one that
shows all the different people that had
ted nugent's there once a year.
Every year around July.
Dance around stage.
Yeah,
all the time.
But he's good.
He's good friends with him so he's not
the best place to do stand up because
they make people stand in the back.
You know that people get seated in the
front,
they stay in the back,
will show up tall people that have for
you last time.
But that was the problem was it already
happened November 18th.
Oh Shit.
But it was a.
There was a lot of people there,
but I had a deal with them.
I said,
I only want to sell tickets to the
people that get to sit down.
I go,
as soon as you run out of seed to
tickets,
I go stop selling tickets.
And the guy kept filling the place like,
oh,
what are you doing?
He goes,
well,
people are still buying tickets.
I go,
well,
they'll stop selling them like you have
a deal.
If the contract is you're not supposed
to have people standing up like I was
going to get less money so that people
could have a seat like because it'd be
better and better.
It's a lot better and he's like,
yeah,
but we're still selling tickets.
Like alright,
we're done.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Like you know what the contract is dude.
Like they just decided to smoosh
everybody in there.
It's just not as fun to stand around and
watch comedy.
I really didn't.
When I went to see doug once doug was
doing a lot of those bar shows,
standing room shows and then went there
as much as I love Doug and it was like
concrete someplace in Hollywood.
We were standing there in my fucking
your legs start hurting like this is not
fun.
I don't want to just stay in here.
I want to sit down.
Like you don't enjoy it as much if
you're not sitting down when you start
talking.
Yes,
and the conscious just goes away from
the standing by the 40 minute mark.
It's like a light talk.
Yup.
In the room and you can't blame them.
You could be throwing heat,
but a couple of weeks ago at this thing
I got there and they had 200 people
standing up to argue with the fucking
guy.
Now I was nothing you can do.
I didn't even think about it and I could
feel him onstage and you can work
through a little bit,
but you feel at this stabbing man.
I remember when we used to do the House
of Blues in Vegas.
Yeah.
That whole back area was still with
people standing and talking and the two
bars bars to the left and a bar to the
right.
Chaos,
chaos.
Just not a good place to do.
Stand up.
It's not the environment,
but whatever.
Businesses,
business,
selling tickets.
I'll put them in the bathroom they want
to listen to.
Yeah,
I wouldn't do that either.
I don't like a lot of those music shows
too.
You got to stand.
I'm going to be used later.
I'm like,
no wonder I got people throwing punches
and aerosmith one time because the
fucking stand that man.
Yeah.
You get tired of it after awhile.
Now I always dance around.
You'll be okay now.
At music shows you sit down and then you
stand up to you on your feet the whole
time.
I don't know.
I've never been to those things,
those music shows or just an excuse for
people to get fucking hammered.
Go see a bunch of bands.
Wander around the desert or wherever the
fuck they talking about.
Oh,
go,
go.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Just dust bowls and pick and fucking
dust out of your teeth and eyes and
you've got to camp at three.
Then
I think Ari camped didn't already do
that.
He went to Coachella and camp now.
Which one was coachella?
This is the ones in California.
Okay.
Yeah,
and then the south by southwest was,
which is an Austin.
There's a bunch of these little music
festivals now.
I guess it's fun if you go to them.
I mean it's gotta be fun.
No,
it's gotta be fun.
You get to see a bunch of different
people.
You're outside of the few days.
You also have to be into it,
you know,
but like when people want to invite you
to those standup ones,
do you ever go to stand up festivals?
Do you do those?
I just did what you did with the Houston
one.
How was that?
Great.
Wasn't as is a fairly new one,
right?
How long have they been doing this one?
I think two or three years.
Man.
Houston used to be a hub.
He used to be a hub.
Somebody could figure out how to open up
that old laptop and river oaks and it's
still there.
It's still there.
That's insane at this.
Somebody said,
God damn it,
I want to look.
They filled that.
There's so much to tell.
That helium guy,
that motherfucker would go down there
and scoop it up.
That was the one of the best rooms ever
and nothing's there now?
I don't think so.
I think that the one club had it for
awhile.
One club was renting it out and then.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Didn't John Wesley and have something to
do with it for awhile?
One of those guys.
All those guys,
but those guys aren't even around no
more.
I'm like,
it's a whole new regime.
Wow.
Those young guys have.
They're running.
That festival was a great festival.
Had some great names,
uh,
that Tony Hinchcliffe at red.
I mean,
we had a great time.
They have a scene was like their uh,
uh,
Houston scene now.
Yeah,
but they're all younger,
younger,
like you see the new.
I tell you where I went.
That's the Houston of 99.
Want me to where it is now?
Portland,
Oregon.
Really?
Portland,
Oregon is the new big.
I mean comedy,
is that the whole.
It's huge right now.
Comedy is huge right now.
You know,
these all these cities have one marquis
room to little underground room and
those to 100 grand rooms are selling out
to laugh factory.
Chicago sells out Brian Morton every
Saturday it will feature x are at an all
time high,
but Portland is at an all time fucking.
Hi,
this is the fourth year in a row.
I've been there one or two with you
before that.
It just keeps getting better and better.
And you hear who's collect that.
I was there Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Amy was there.
She sold that somewhere.
I'm fucking 12,000 seats.
I don't know what you did on Thursday
night.
That just proves it's out.
It's out in the back when you were in
Columbus a few months ago,
animal burris and the lead were in town.
I mean this is every week and all three
shows were selling,
you know,
2000 seats.
Comedy is at an all time high,
but Portland is the Houston have to.
You could see it.
You could see when people talk to you
afterward who they,
they come and they talked to you about
commonly.
Like,
I'm coming here to see Segora.
I'm coming here to see this guy.
I'm coming here to see that guy coming
for fucking comedy,
man.
Yeah.
They're smart place.
Portland's a smart place and that they
appreciate art St.
same with Seattle.
Seattle's a very smart place.
Saddles a notch above La and a lot of
ways like when it comes to like,
um,
smaller community,
it's the people a little slicker.
They're just not show Biz effected,
you know,
the more themselves.
I shouldn't say slicker,
I should say,
just smoother.
You know what I mean?
They're like more themselves,
like they're not as affected overall.
There'll be a great place if they
developed a big scene.
I know they got the comedy underground
there and that other places.
Fantastic.
Paula,
that's amazing.
That same pool halls,
they'll pull all connected to it.
Really got some other room satellites
around,
but I mean that's everywhere now from
Indianapolis to everywhere.
It got some satellite rooms going on
comedies.
Big Man.
Yeah.
Comedy is getting big.
I mean,
helium does a secret show.
What's the secret show?
They don't know who the headliners.
Rarely and they sell out.
No Shit.
No,
no.
Philadelphia in Portland,
Oregon.
Wednesday night you want to do is just
call the guy and go,
I want the secret show.
I want to work out in front of a real.
Well,
I don't know.
She's going to get Joe Rogan people and
yet people not job.
Wow.
Sell out.
We don't even know who the headliner is
and they know me to do a club.
We just know it's going to be one of the
guys who's here during the week.
I already did it.
He sold that.
Didn't know what was interesting.
Very.
That's a great concept.
That's a minor risk.
That's great.
It's going to be one of these 20 cats.
You don't know who it's going to be.
Strap a pair on just for the show.
Yeah.
Instead of red band secret show,
here's the secret Chelan and put 30
people on the poster.
Like what's the secret pitch?
I'm looking at all the fucking people
plus surprise guest.
Uh,
okay.
That's your secret.
The secret with him is you don't know.
You don't know who the MC is.
That's a real feature or the headline.
Nobody knows.
He just comes up on stage Wednesday
night.
Wow.
Good,
good.
I did well when you asked,
when you have a real reputation,
that's when you're telling me that
you're just a fan of comedy.
You know what?
I just want to fucking laugh at you.
You're telling me,
you know,
and I don't really like him.
I like him.
I didn't really like him.
It's also like a real good example of
the reputation of the club.
Like they trust the club so much.
The club as so many headlines connected
to it,
like real top level headliners that they
know that you're in touch with these
people all the time and you'll put the
right kind of person in that and they do
it every week,
once a month,
once a month.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
Portland,
Seattle,
all those Pacific northwest people.
It's like,
it's a,
it's a different vibe up there,
you know,
that whole,
uh,
Pacific vibe.
It's just a different vibe.
I only seeing the sun for two hours.
Yeah,
three days.
The summertime though,
they're out.
They're out.
Know that.
See the summer,
it's tough to sell a ticket up there
because those motherfuckers got to go
camping.
Yeah,
I got it.
They got,
they're out there.
I'll do a music.
They had been,
they had been living in like fucking a
Jack Nicholson in the shining fucking
six months.
It rains every goddamn day.
I remember Joe saying,
Hey,
what'd you think about Seattle?
So yeah,
that was great.
She was great.
Like Colorado's great until you see
waiting for three weeks in a row.
Colorado doesn't have that problem
though.
Whites,
one time it did really in 83 fucking
Paul Harvey was in the middle of
November,
yelling,
we don't know what's going to happen in
Colorado this year.
A Paul Harvey,
the weather guy,
radio guy.
He was just talking about the apps in
Colorado on all these mountains in
Colorado.
Empty.
We'll let be a snow season bitch.
It started snowing on the 20th and it
went straight to the December 23rd.
Well,
you know what?
Twenty days in a row and snow is bro.
No,
you have no idea.
Think of leaving for work on a bus.
It's snowing.
Getting out.
It's six.
It's snowing.
Going home.
Going to bed.
You wake up.
It's still snowing.
Two days is cool.
Twenty days,
20 days.
Snowing,
shovelling every.
I was shoveling the snow too for awhile,
so I'd have to get up and down.
I was getting 10,
12 bucks an hour to shower.
I didn't give a fuck how deep it again.
Eight inches.
12 inches a day.
You know how fast the snow comes down in
Colorado doors or eight feet?
They probably.
Yeah,
they had.
It's like you either pay me now pay me
that I don't know what the basis for the
fucking bottom of the hill,
but they got the snow they needed that
year because they man make the hill.
The snow on the bottom right there.
That helps out.
They man make the snow on the bottom I
think.
Okay,
whatever.
Whatever that fake snow but snow,
they just make it with the machine.
They just make it with the machine.
Then on top fills in those gaps,
but the bottom gives it more of a base.
That's what it's called.
The base that's so they'll tell you we
got a 63 inch base.
We have a $200 base.
That means you could jump off a fucking
helicopter and nothing's going to happen
to you in that base.
Two of them,
it just used to going to land in powder
puff.
You imagine doing that,
going to my arm and get in the
helicopter and just jumping off the
helicopter with skis and just landing on
that fucking thing
without your knee blowing the fuck up.
Yeah.
I saw a guy who did that video.
He jumped like 250 feet and went up,
fucking landed in the powder and nothing
happened.
No nothing.
It's fine.
Fresh Virgin fucking powder.
You couldn't take a big chance though.
You got to know exactly what's under
that spot.
Can you imagine landing?
That's a fucking Ayesha.
When they call.
Oh my God.
My big icicle goes up.
Your asshole
or hit a rock on the way down.
Ink.
Yeah.
No,
I like,
I like bad weather but not three weeks
and I fucking in Seattle.
I.
So I lived there in [inaudible] 95,
96.
They get parts.
November dog.
It just rains for three weeks.
Are you worried about global warming in
la?
Oh yeah.
I can't sleep at night.
Fuck global warming.
It's fucking 44 degrees this morning.
I can't.
I'm magical.
Yeah,
it's called in La this morning.
Forty four.
But then it goes up.
Uh,
you know,
if they talked a lot about global
warming.
Let me get that half a joint dog over
there because this shit fucking turned
that on me.
Give me one of those fucking.
You're a freshman now.
Do
all your buddies got?
Yeah,
he gave these fucking strong.
He's an animal.
He's a fucking animal play games.
What were you struggling with when you
were talking about yesterday?
So it's legal now.
$100.
I could call him up right now.
It's legal.
Yeah.
I don't know where he's allowed to
deliver it to.
I think he has to deliver it to somebody
that's nowhere near a church or a school
or something like that.
He's got the stars or two stars at that
height.
Times.
Picking the number three fucking edible.
Dude.
I never even need a full point for the
star of death.
I don't even have full point.
I leave a little bit.
They take a little bit.
I take a bite,
but I make sure I leave a little bit of
the point.
Listen to me.
There's these new things called cushy
200 milligrams.
You open it up.
It smells like transmission fluid when
you.
It's like when you fucking finger
somebody but you smelled deepened the
monkey.
It smells like gunpowder and the pussy
St.
it smells like transmission fluid in
this fucking motherfucker go.
You get so fucked up.
I love that.
Shit.
I just pass out now,
when I was in Colorado I got some gum,
drops,
some,
a pot gumdrops God,
they were so good.
Holy Shit.
I don't know how many milligrams.
Yeah,
but each one felt like somewhere around
20.
You know,
he had a couple of those and they give
you a bag that's supposed to be 100
milligrams for how many is in there?
Five and their attending or whatever it
is.
But it's got a kick.
It's hard to tell if they're right
because I had one and I was like,
yeah,
this feels like about 10 milligrams now.
Another one that was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
Like I don't buy that.
Have that consistent.
I don't think they're doing such a good
job at stirring,
you know the stars.
Last week I was fucking drooling.
I called the guy and go and see what the
fuck bro.
What was in these stores this week?
And he goes,
well I'm.
Sometimes you got a batch is stronger
than the other.
It's like,
wait luge,
when I was a kid with Qualia,
because people make them in that
basement.
So something like we talked about
sometimes to the table is like this,
you know what I'm saying?
All this shit goes to the bottom and
your fuck.
Yeah.
And if you get a bag of gummies,
you're not necessarily getting them from
the same plant.
You know what I mean?
One,
one gummy might be from one batch and
another gummy might be for another
batch.
Like it might not mean they're all
getting piled up together.
Scooped and put into a bag.
You easily could have one live one in
their dog.
Had an old article about a month ago I
found the back of my drawer that they
fucked me up.
Well that's like an expired vicodin.
You ever taken an expired?
You won't have paid for a weekend of
mouth.
I don't care how many root canals they
give you.
Time expired biking my pants,
my wife's,
my wife.
And watch that tell you about that.
A lot of the surgery,
surgery,
I pop that motherfucking after it was
washing detergent.
Stronger than ever.
I just found it.
I found it took one hour with me in case
I had tooth pain or no pain.
And I never wore those pants again.
I go to Portland,
I go on the pants and that her,
she watched it right before I went
onstage.
I pop that motherfucking
who gives a fuck?
I don't need to know anymore.
I've been through everything.
I do nothing.
How strong was it?
Oh my God.
I picked a half on stage and I blacked
out
like the first 30 minutes.
I couldn't wait to get back to the hotel
room seat.
The other
radio next day.
Oh my God.
Black the fuck.
I didn't know what came out of my mouth.
When you on radio,
you just start swearing.
No,
no,
no.
I'm headed to Portland Thursday night.
I'm in Portland.
I'm getting dressed.
When I was pulling pants,
these pants are darker than my usual
jeans.
I never wore.
I didn't want.
Well last time I wore them was probably
when I had the surgery and that's why I
found the pill in that it would clean.
I went into the detergent,
had won the numbers down.
She could have been anything.
So I just,
I slept me not be an answer.
I'll eat the whole thing.
People give me crazy shit all the time.
Let me break this.
Maybe somebody gave it to me and I
watched over it.
I knew it was like a viking cousin for
the Vicodin,
you know what I'm saying?
They had to be a cousin or a brother in
law,
something if I could.
If I popped in.
I took a half and went to Portland.
I walked up those stairs and when I sat
down on top of it then I was like,
I'm fucked up.
I smoked dogs,
but I tell you,
I set the fire alarm off and put the
glove on.
Friday night,
the fight in the dressing room and the
fire department had to come because the
whole club blacks out,
all the lights go out and the.
I had to go onstage and fucking Felicia
what up with me?
He's just like,
do you want me to call up there and
check it out?
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's how much of a comedy store chick
she is.
Like somebody else has said,
well,
well let's wait till they put the mic
on.
She's comedy store.
She looked at me and said,
do you want me to still go up?
And I go,
fuck.
Yeah,
and when she got up to the mic turned
on.
Oh,
that's perfect.
Perfect.
But that just goes to show you the
confidence of the comedy store.
Did you tell them that you did that?
Did you set it off?
No,
the Co,
the MC was onstage.
And what I'm saying,
he hit bad pain,
pain,
and the lights are blinking.
And when you went up there,
he didn't say that was me smoking.
Once I got took two hits,
I tell them the truth.
I just took two
fucking heads.
Wow.
That's a pretty fucking sensitive.
Fire alarm was right over me.
It was right there.
I looked at it afterwards.
So the next night they put a little
helmet on it.
Did they discover oh fuck yeah.
They put a little heart without that
motherfucker.
Hilarious.
So it's drastic.
It's just a drastic,
drastic system.
Right.
Shut the power off and everything.
How about I keep the lights on?
What do you think when stampede the fire
department came?
Looks at the manager and he goes,
somebody smoking in the green room.
He goes,
yeah,
he goes out it,
we'll set it up and that was it.
They didn't give me a ticket or not.
And thank God.
That's nice.
Yeah.
A lot of people probably think they can,
you know,
like especially if you're at a,
uh,
like any sort of a rock venue like those
rock theaters and stuff like that.
How many people have probably been
smoking in those things forever?
Forever.
Fuck.
It's probably standard.
Portland is an interesting place and the
people who live there say it's getting
kind of weird because then you're
getting a bunch of people that want to
live in Portland moving there instead of
Portland people.
People are like,
yeah,
I think Portland's kind of my kind of
see cameron lives in Eugene Moreau.
Yeah.
Somewhere in Oregon,
right?
Yeah.
Because one of his neighbors came to the
show.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they came to the show.
He lives in Eugene,
which is like a smaller college town.
Have you been there to visit?
You like it?
Eugene's great.
I like it.
I like that with good Chinese restaurant
there.
Quaaludes.
I really kind of loons is in Eugene and
Roseburg at Roseburg is the one where
that's the fucked up one.
That's the one where the.
They have a strip club,
but the waitresses,
everything.
She used to strip with the DJ.
That grown.
Man,
you got to see this fucking beauty,
but are we getting this fucking fun man?
Oh,
that's a great drive to.
I wonder what cow means.
I don't know.
What it means is a challenge.
There's a bunch of different
restaurants.
There was a balloon.
Saugus,
Massachusetts.
Remember that?
Chinese restaurant club?
Yeah.
Was Nick's comedy stop at the Calhoun?
I wonder what that means.
It goes to city.
A city.
Oh,
okay.
Like New York,
like it's like saying Hollywood.
Is it like saying like the Hollywood
restaurant,
the Hollywood grill,
the Hollywood diner.
That's a funny thing,
right?
That word Hollywood.
Like people like to use that word.
It's the northern part of Hong Kong.
Oh,
no,
shit.
They ain't go
to.
Maybe it's like a style of cooking or
something,
but yeah,
that was the cow loon and Sagas.
Great Place.
Great Comedy Club.
How Far Sagas from the city?
I don't remember whether it couldn't
have been too long.
Were there a couple and it was run by
Lenny's brother.
There was.
No,
that was giggles lady brother,
brother Mike Clark ran a place called
giggles and uh,
that Guy Mike Clark gave me more
headline and gigs,
like when I was struggling than probably
anybody.
He had always had great rooms.
Always had a restaurant here or dive
there,
a bar there and always got you good
money.
It was cool.
It was fun too because you,
you travel around all these weird spots.
Do Comedy and sometimes people would
hire comedians and it wouldn't work out.
They would try it for one show and you'd
be on that one show and then they never
had comedy again.
It was such a dirty comedians from
Boston come up in some weird fish
restaurant in New Hampshire and they
just don't want to just don't like it.
How many of those did we do?
Thousands.
Had to.
I used to do comedy in a place where it
was alive.
Parrot behind John Stayed Two,
three feet.
He would eat the seeds and fucking flick
them up.
In the end.
There's so many things that you've done
that you were talking about comedy.
You have this grand illusion of comedy
when you get into it and you get to this
place and it's not a stage.
There's no green room guy talks to you
like you're shit.
You're like,
why do I do this?
You know,
my 12 and I got to go to work at six.
So fucking tough.
But it's not a,
it's not really a,
you know,
it also doesn't seem that hard when you
look at it from the outside the first
time you look at it,
like that's not that hard.
It's just people talking like,
I'll figure that out.
Yeah,
until you bomb 800 fucking times.
But that's part of it.
Like now sometimes I get happy when I
bombed because I get it out of the what?
Yeah.
At least it's not a fucking surprise
anymore.
Yeah.
That's the best motivator to like
tighten up your game.
The best motivators are shitty.
Said.
It's nothing like one offset just feels.
Just wanting to get back and tighten
things down.
It's interesting to people that go to
the store on a regular basis too,
because they get to see all the
development.
They'll see a bit one time and then
they'll come back and see you maybe six
months later and they'll see it again.
But now it's got all these extra things
going on.
It's alive.
It's connected to other.
To get into it better.
You're smoother in your delivery.
So much fucking fun.
The CSO thing,
you shot in Chicago?
Uh,
in Rosemont,
Illinois,
right?
You shot it pretty recently.
October 15th.
That's real recent and it comes out
tomorrow.
How fired up you?
I'm happy it's old.
There's a lot of fucking work.
It wasn't.
Yeah,
it was fun though.
It was really fun.
You know,
it was the first time I have a tape,
my spouse,
myself,
I can't stand looking at myself and I
can't stand listening to myself and I
don't know which one is worse,
you know?
I never said nothing to nobody,
but I saw Johnny Depp on Letterman and
let him and was like,
so all the dailies.
Luckily he's like,
bitch,
I don't look at them and let them.
It's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
He goes,
I don't look at Shit.
I don't go to the premiere of my movies.
I don't look at myself.
And he goes,
why not?
I lunch and I felt a lot better,
but this was the first time he said he
hated looking at themselves.
This I don't like it.
You don't want me to say is um,
when I first got here January 29th and
like two weeks later it was super bowl
and I got talked into going on with
these goofy active parties.
I didn't know I was at the store.
I was at the store and some goofy guy
came up and he goes,
you want to go to the superbowl party?
And I went there and I'll never forget
this as long as I fucking live in the
middle of the fucking super bowl.
Like,
you know when it ends the first quarter,
then you have the show in the middle and
Michael Jackson,
which saying or whatever.
Right in front of 60 people,
a person put a demo reel.
I will never forget that my whole life.
Like it was not supposed to be in that.
Like some guy came in and go,
it's time yet.
Hold on.
I don't know for my demo reel when Shit,
you found anything and they popped that
demo reel in for 15 minutes.
You Watch student films and fucking
college films and I think he had like
one spot that was tv and I'll never
forget how embarrassing.
Like I felt embarrassed for the guy.
Like let's watch my demo reel.
Are you fucking kidding me?
To a room full of other actors?
60.
Oh my comedian.
Stand up comics,
you know,
so called man.
I Dunno,
I would just been here for two weeks.
So I don't like looking at none of this
shit.
This was the first time I actually went
home and fucking tape sets.
Like I didn't know how to do nothing on
this fucking phone.
And I went home and tape fucking sets
and had to listen to them and write
notes and I realized the process there
was shit.
I was letting go at night like you come
up to and go,
that's a good bit.
But you didn't tell me about the two
things before that.
I said that comes after a set.
It's really hard to remember what it
was.
Funny.
I don't know why that is,
but you remember one or two lines,
but you didn't remember those two
fluctuations you set in your voice.
Those are the things I never worked on
before.
That line that you threw away,
that was the setup to that joke and you
don't even know you set it up with that.
That's what this taught me.
This special taught me that type of
shit.
I had to listen to every fucking set
man.
And you know what?
It's funny how you prepare jokes and you
think what's going to work.
And then when you listen,
the ship that you thought was gonna work
doesn't really work as well.
It's little things that you didn't think
was going to work.
That really worked.
It's so weird when you listen to your
material and it was a whole complete
different education.
For me.
It was rough for me to do.
It was really tough for me to do because
I didn't like listening to myself at
night.
I would do it on planes when you can't
go anywhere.
When I'm trapped I get really fucking
high.
I pull one of these pads out and just go
on a train on the plane.
I'm sorry.
In fact,
you know what happened to me.
I pulled out my third seat.
Deanna.
Plane out of Chicago is the worst thing
I ever heard in my fucking life,
but my cd is
probably the worst thing I've ever heard
in all my life.
I can't believe I haven't really used
it,
but that's when I learned that there's a
lot of jokes in times that even if you
think even [inaudible] there's seven
minutes,
you're like enough with the shit.
There's still three more,
four more minutes in that thing.
When I beat and you taught me that you
will.
The one that said you liked to keep
finding tags and stuff.
You know,
sometimes you just get tired,
you just go,
fuck it.
I got four of them on there,
I'm going to move on.
So that's what I found that out.
That's what shocked me about this.
It was the first time I had really done
this type of exclusive work,
Bro.
CSOS putting out some good shit.
You Doug,
who else are they doing?
Brian?
Bryan County.
In fact,
I'm doing radio.
I'm calling radio tomorrow and Brian
zombies in Florida.
This is Brian's last one.
Did they buy his last one on one with
them?
I'm not sure.
I know either got released last week and
I'm not sure either I or reissue or
something.
See.
So uh,
so cecil was owned by NBC,
is that what it is?
Yes.
That's interesting.
They're doing that.
Look,
it's great when someone's doing any.
I mean the more people doing something
like that,
the better.
Like I said,
man right now commonly used to be eight
to 12 or eight to two.
Now it's nine to five because people are
on their desks with ear buds on.
Yeah.
They could dream your fucking special at
work.
There's so much going on with streaming
and the whole fucking deal.
Well,
most of the people that listen to this
are working right now.
I'm working on right now.
Probably.
I would imagine if you're doing
something that you don't have to be
listening to somebody.
You could listen to this while you're
doing your work.
Nine to five,
nine has shown any Goddamn I got to stop
coughing.
The fuck's going on.
I ended up five has so many amazing.
You know from TV.
Used to be from eight to 11.
Yeah.
Pretty much working people only watch
television from eight to 11.
That's changed.
Now.
I go to work now at nine and put it buds
on and I can't get into game of thrones
or Westworld,
but I can listen to a here.
How many people do you think get to
listen to stuff while they work?
A lot.
What percentage?
I T I don't know about it.
A lot of tech people.
Yeah.
When I talk to my knees sometimes in
Jersey,
she tells me I was to you in the office
and she's in marketing.
You know,
it puts these in and make notes and type
of proposals and listening to podcasts.
It's a whole game out.
That's not eight to 11 no more.
That thing is that now?
Yeah,
eight till 11.
Netflix is a whole new realm now.
You know.
Now I could go to work and listening
from nine to 12 and from one to five and
I could watch from 12 to one at my desk.
I could watch game of thrones on
Netflix.
I can watch.
It's a different fucking world out
there.
Do you use a use Netflix and use apple
TV?
Do you ever use that?
No.
That's what we're getting because the
speakers on my.
I was fantastic.
I didn't know what my wife is saying.
I don't understand of that stuff.
She does
all the it stuff at the house.
It's just crazy that you can see.
You know what I mean?
Ninety nine or whatever the hell it is.
Percentage of the movies just by the
right.
They're like,
I don't know what percentage.
I shouldn't say 99.
Let's take a guess.
It's probably not even 10 percent.
What percent of all movies are on itunes
because independent movies probably
aren't.
Maybe some independent movies,
all movies on itunes a lot.
I don't think all of them because the
other day I noticed that they just
recently added an American Werewolf in
London and I was like,
oh wow.
How weird was it?
The wolf man,
one of those.
Now when we told them on Netflix,
this is apple TV.
Then they recently added some other
movies that were like pretty old movies,
like they just.
They just added them,
so I think they're still buying movies
and putting them on me.
I don't know how they're doing licensing
them,
whatever they're doing,
making some sort of a deal,
but they got a lot of fucking movies is
my point.
The crazy thing is you could just press
it and it starts playing.
Like when we were kids.
It's just the idea of going to the
store.
You got make member have blockbuster
would have those giant shelves filled
with one kind of movie.
One movie would come out and that movie
would just feel a shelf and like say if
it was like a transformers or alien or
something like that,
there would be,
you know,
three,
four levels of them and you would,
you would get there and they don't want
to be a couple left and you get lucky.
Oh God,
we got the last,
last alien.
Yeah,
bring it back.
That's what I,
that's the first time I went in.
There was a night I was running from the
cops.
After I kidnap Vela,
I want the blockbuster and I,
and above the law,
these people kept telling me,
you gotTa Watch,
watch this Guy Steven Seagal.
I'm like,
I don't want to do it.
I watched above the law and lethal
weapon.
I'd never seen lethal weapon before.
That's a good movie for the time.
If I watched it too,
that probably get angry.
I watched the triangle scene at the end.
Like a mad catch.
Mel Gibson used a triangle.
Doesn't even close it on the Chinese.
A guy with them two sponges.
No,
it wasn't in.
Um,
yeah.
Lethal weapon.
Do the check.
Was it the gas guy?
He's hanging in.
The guy's hitting them with the sponges
and the guy.
That's right.
He triangles and.
No,
and then he triangles.
Guy On grass guy we fuck with the guy
who got into a motorcycle accident.
PUC
Puc.
Yeah.
It was Gary Busey,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a shitty triangle.
Choke to.
He doesn't cinch it up.
And this is like when the cops were
there,
they kind of let them go after it.
Right.
Because this was like these guys so
crazy.
The cops let them fight.
Let them go with sticks.
Mel Gibson was shredded son.
That's her motherfucking caboodle.
Time for this shit.
Look at him.
Yeah.
Mel Gibson,
if people will forget,
was a fucking accident star.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Boom.
We get slammed on a cop car.
This is so ridiculous like that this
could ever happen or cops would let some
bad guy duke it out with the cop because
they knew that the cop was such a bad
ass.
He's eventually gonna kick this de
Gaulle's today.
Thirty years ago this shit was
happening.
Do you think so they let dudes do like
as a friend who called out a compliment
and fought in front of three other cops.
Well,
he just said you wouldn't do this shit
without your tough friends.
Take off the fucking badge and the gun.
Bitch.
Why are we doing this?
Take it off.
You're not going to do it.
And then he goes,
yes,
I am.
Guy Looked like Phil Sims.
We were like in high school,
we were maybe a year in high school when
Phil Sims a beat cop for one of my
friends on the street to other cops.
They're like six of us there.
Who One?
My friend.
Fuck them up.
Really my friend.
That's how crazy it was.
Why are we doing this?
You don't like me,
I don't like you.
Forget the arrest and let's drill down
right here.
You will.
Tough guy.
Motherfucker put off the gun.
So after he beat his ass with a cop,
do they fucking shook hands and then it
will fuck with each other again.
Wow.
I mean,
he didn't throw him around,
but he punched him in the fucking mouth
a few times in front of his buddies.
Oh,
that's weird.
And one time when I got,
when I got out of the fucking jail in
Boulder,
I got out of the halfway house and I got
into a fight with a guy that cut me off
and they ended up splitting up the car
and something happened,
Bro.
I slipped and that guy had me.
He was beating the fuck out of me,
but then he slipped in the snow.
So when the cops got there,
I was on.
They pulled this up.
I was going back to prison.
I thought they were going to violate me.
I told the cop what happened.
He told the cop what happened,
but he was giving the cop a bad attitude
I want right there.
He was telling me,
what the fuck do you care?
And the guy goes,
hey,
awesome.
They talked and they pull us back.
I just told the cop the truth.
I just got to the halfway house.
I can't get violated for this.
Go talk to this guy.
And they came back and I go,
we're not going to press charges but
shake hands.
And the guy goes,
I'm not going to shake his hand.
And the cop looks at me,
looks at them.
He goes,
you know what?
When we got here,
you weren't doing too fucking good.
Okay.
Don't make me.
Don't make me put him on fucking top.
You'll get you weren't doing too fucking
good.
Shake his hand.
The guy shook my hand.
That was the end of that.
We got it.
You weren't doing it through good
cops letting people fight.
It's strange.
You remember there was that thing that
was going on in the California prisons
where they haven't liked these,
these crazy fights,
these underground fights and the guards
were like setting things up.
The gladiator fights.
Remember that?
There was like a big article about it.
We should.
I don't know if we let at days.
Next time you see Mike Dyson,
you should have asked them before like
shoes.
True.
See what he says to you that they based
that movie with fuck.
Go on him.
That was the story that somebody,
they let the board
and leave town for Christmas and one of
the guys got in touch with to promote
and they brought somebody from boxing
and to see Mike Tyson.
Come on.
That's what I got the fucking idea for
that movie.
Let me go.
Come on.
Undisputed.
Let me.
Excuse me.
Let me go ahead and pick that kid.
Undisputed is based on a real story.
They brought a guy in the prison.
Come on.
Do you know how,
how much that would be worth
when prison guards force inmates to
fight?
That was the wide.
You.
Uh,
what are you googling?
Undisputed movie real?
Is it based on a real story?
Wow.
Movie similarities to real life.
Tyson's saga.
Undisputed.
But where is the fight that he didn't
have a fight in jail?
If Mike Tyson had a fight in jail,
they would have,
they would have filmed that
and Mike Tyson would be talking about
it.
Mike Tyson has that whole story.
You know,
where your,
his whole live show where he talks about
his entire life.
I mean,
if Mike Tyson had that in his life,
he will be telling people about it.
Don't you think?
I mean,
I can imagine that he would ever have a
fight in jail and not tell anybody about
it.
I think the.
Well,
what was it about it?
What are you looking up?
Jamie Center for?
Um,
someone was asking the same question as
a boxing for them.
So yeah,
maybe someone's got a link somewhere.
People are silly.
There's no links.
You would have heard of it.
We've known there was a video of Tyson
fighting in jail.
Come on.
And she for sure you're going to tape.
It was just going to let it happen.
Trust your memory.
You're going to bring in riddick bow or
someone like that.
And you're gonna.
Have Tyson fight him in jail.
The Fuck Outta here.
That's ridiculous.
Early nineties.
Mid Nineties.
I don't remember the exact day.
When.
What year do you think Tyson was in
jail?
Tyson went to jail.
A 2000.
Two thousand 11 around there.
No,
that was,
that was the more recent one,
right?
Wasn't the real Chicago and Illinois.
I think it was the late nineties because
he was out.
He was out and fighting holy field while
I was living in Encino,
which I think was 96.
Yeah,
I think.
When did he go in?
He got arrested in [inaudible] 92 that
says you got a six year prison term.
Yeah,
that was the one.
It was awesome.
It was.
That's what it was.
How long was Tyson in jail for?
He still maintains that of all the shit
he says that,
that that's,
that doesn't happen.
Yeah.
That was set up,
which is really crazy.
Then you find out that that same woman
had set somebody else up.
She had lied about a,
another one.
Another.
Uh,
alleged rape allegedly lied.
I don't know the specifics,
but that was in her past,
like,
whoa.
You just
released a winter in March.
March 26.
Ninety two.
He was sentenced.
He was released march.
[inaudible] 95.
Three years?
Yeah,
three years.
How long has he been retired?
He retired right after.
Well,
he had a couple of fights,
but I think it was the Kevin Ferguson
fight.
Was that the one where you retired?
Was his last fight.
Tyson's done the boxing world by
quitting before the start of the seventh
round against Kevin Mcbride.
Kevin Mcbride.
Okay.
That's what it was.
And uh,
you know,
the Lennox Lewis fight was a bad beating
two.
That was before that.
That was one where you look,
you knew like,
oh,
he's just not the same guy anymore.
You know,
you go back and watch the guy that
destroyed Larry Holmes.
It was a scary guy.
Then you know,
he knew as much as anybody knew,
can only go so long in that business.
It's just,
is a shelf life.
Nobody gets out.
You know,
it's a fun time for boxing right now.
Been paying attention to boxing
belly up time for what I got on my
plate.
Now I got to open up boxing.
You Know Bernard Hopkins is fighting?
No.
Yup.
Fifty,
50 1:51.
He's fighting December 17th.
Where in La?
It's fight at the forum.
Yeah.
Who's he fighting?
Some.
A young,
tough light.
Heavyweight white dude.
Knockout power will say barnard is so
hard to hit.
He's so clever.
I don't think he'd be fighting if he
wasn't still capable to.
He looked at him like right here,
come on,
man.
Fifty one years old and he looks fucking
great.
Like,
look at this.
Who's combinations?
Right?
I mean,
I mean everything looks smooth as fuck,
man.
That's,
that's the real Bernard Hopkins.
When you're looking at him boxing here,
you're not saying,
oh,
this is a 51 year old Bernard Hopkins.
You're saying that's Bernard Hopkins.
Oh Joe,
51.
Your reactions,
your vision.
There's a lot of other factors.
Oh,
for sure.
There's a lot of the factors,
but this is amazing.
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's amazing that you could even
consider that this guy at 51 years old
should be allowed to fight
professionally.
There's also very smart.
He was.
You've pointed out a lot of stuff.
To me,
he was always very smart.
He never really got hit a lot.
He didn't get in any big,
big,
big people,
you know.
I mean,
this guy always stayed pretty clean.
It's not like he's a Jeffrey Jeff,
you know?
Yeah.
I know.
He would make fights ugly.
He would clench a lot,
frustrated a lot of guys,
but he also could crack,
you know,
and he just was a really boxer.
The the big coming out party for him was
Felix Trinidad when he fought Felix
Trinidad and just boxes face off.
Everybody just saw like wow.
Like we thought Felix Trinidad was this
young hungry lion.
He was taken on the older veteran who is
probably on his way down to Bernard
Hopkins,
wasn't on his way down like he's just,
he was just like coming into his own
stride then,
but he's always been so disciplined,
man so smart with his diet.
So smart with how he takes care of his
body.
Never allows himself to get out of
shape.
So he's never like working back into
shape and always fights intelligent and
defensively he's always in the right
position to work for him.
That's why I 51,
it might work for very well could.
He's working out with John David
Jackson,
who was a two division world champ,
I believe.
I think he was at least one division
champ,
but John,
David Jackson and a lot of people forgot
about it was a really high level voxer
and like,
uh,
like the nineties.
This guy here.
Yep.
Yeah.
John.
David Jackson.
He looks familiar.
He works with Sergei Cova love him and
Sergey Kovalev work together.
So that was a,
that was another guy that he trains.
He trains.
He's like one of the most respected up
and coming trainers particularly because
he achieved a world championship level,
you know,
when he was boxing,
he was really high level guy.
He uh,
used to work out with Terry Clay Bond,
you know Terry Cleveland as to what's
really going on.
That guy.
I love that dude.
He said it's some gym in Hollywood,
I guess to stop by say hi to.
I saw justin fortune.
How's that guy doing?
Cancer could suck his dick though.
What happened?
He had cancer for a while,
but I touched them.
Yes.
I think he beat the fuck out it though,
Pete.
The last night when I drove around,
but I was really in shock when I hugged
him.
He Salad Bowl.
I mean,
you could tell he lost 20 pounds.
He was doing chemo.
He said,
I know I didn't ask him,
but pro kind of cancer.
Was it like something Roy?
The sunlight,
some thyroid or something,
something like that.
But man,
when I hugged them yesterday I was like,
this guy got cancer.
God Damn God damn well you know,
they're way better at taking care of
cancer now than I've ever been.
Like hitting a wall.
I hadn't seen him in a year.
I could never count them go to Hollywood
that much.
So yes,
I was driving and he's always training
packy out.
He's in the Philippines when I call it
six,
I'm up.
I'll try to call.
I even set them.
I call.
So when he's training,
package out how to him and Freddie Roach
work stuff out that go down there.
So.
But what is,
what is the difference between like what
he does and what Freddy does?
I think he just does strengthen fitness.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And Freddy does the myths and everything
else.
But Justin was one of the first guys
were his gym I ever saw.
He had like an altitude box.
Yes.
I was like,
what?
You go in the box and it simulates high
altitude and you fucking go crazy and
workout in there.
Yes.
Like that's,
that's high level.
I mean he had like a,
it was a vacuum attached to it or
something like that that was sucking the
air out of there.
So it was like a very low oxygen state.
Simulators used to be in the corner.
They moved.
I didn't see it yesterday,
but man,
when I hugged them,
mess that,
I was like,
oh fuck this guy still solid.
Oh Shit.
I'm really interested in seeing Bernard
Hopkins fight this weekend.
I'm really interested in.
No.
Next week.
Next weekend.
Really interest you in town.
No,
no.
I'm going to have to watch it on the
road,
but a 17th going somewhere.
Joe Diaz.
Are you doing comedy?
No job.
I ain't going to bother.
I ain't got a creepy question.
This sucker.
I just thought you were doing comedy.
Somebody didn't know you wanted to set
their next gig.
Booked a past our gig on New Year's
December 31st.
Then I don't have anything booked until
Portland that was working on new shit.
Um,
what about uh,
in Toronto Friday you have no show.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
we do it.
Yeah.
It's me,
Russell Peters and big Jay Oakerson.
That's fucking,
that's like one of those festivals.
Yeah.
We sold out Massey Hall and like an
hour.
It was pretty quick.
What's Massey whole feet?
3,000,
2,800,
something like that?
No,
just one.
Just one.
Just one to have some fun.
It was,
you know,
Russell did the podcast.
We were just joking around or like we
should do a show together.
I'm like,
let's book something man.
And then I'm like,
I'm going to do Massey Hall.
You want to do it with me?
He's like,
fuck it,
I'll do it.
And then boom,
it was in.
And then I've talked to big j.
You know,
actually maybe I talked to big j first.
Asked big j first.
Yeah.
I asked big j first because he told me
was going to be in town for the fights.
He wanted to get tickets to the fight.
So I go,
fuck yeah.
I'm like,
what are you doing Friday night?
And he wasn't doing anything.
I'm like,
C'mon man,
let's work.
It tells for fun.
That place is awesome.
Oh yeah.
The Beatles played there.
Man.
That place has an energy.
3,000 seats,
the fucking Beatles.
But Hey man,
they did whatever the fuck they wanted.
The Beatles could do whatever they
wanted.
They could play 3000 seeds.
They it a paid arenas.
I think they probably did everything.
And I got to Boogie three please.
I gotta tell you this,
wrap this shit up.
No,
we tell to wrap this up.
When I heard this story,
I was like,
I don't want to hear this and I'm not
gonna Watch it.
Listen,
he would call me a bunch of names and
shit and I probably won't say nothing to
you.
Don't fuck with me.
When it comes to music and the argument
by restaurants,
that's what gets under my fucking core.
Okay.
I hate it.
I hate the band.
I don't like a fucking band.
Okay.
When I was growing up in Jersey,
I got a call.
When did it go see?
Twisted sister
and I'm like,
that's the bad.
With the makeup,
like makeup.
I went with this Italian dude that
had no fucking.
He had.
He had no tolerance for bad music.
Me and him a perfect because we walked
out of movies together with perfect for
each other.
We walked in,
I'll never forget this guy came in and
goes,
what?
Twisted fucking sister man,
and we looked at each other and we ran
out.
Never again will,
I think it was the sister dog watched a
documentary on twisted sister the more
than most.
I knew there was selling 9,000 tickets,
no 14,000 tickets a week and nobody
would sign them as a band.
I mean that God awful.
God awful.
That music local,
but they became huge and
nobody would sign them to fucking
assistance would come up to the
president of the label and go dog
twisted system and he goes,
the next person will talk to me about
twisted assistant.
I will fucking fight.
I do not like these guys sold so many,
but it was like for you to understand
this,
you have to understand.
I think I was talking about all this
shit you did when you did comedy.
Do you know that Dee Snider Guy is
jacked Jack,
Jack,
and somebody picked a fight with him
somewhere or something like that.
Either someone picked a fight with him
or there was a guy who looked exactly
like dee snider will beat the fuck out
of some dude.
I forget which one.
It's one of those.
It's either it's either I got fooled and
they revealed they were revealed that it
was a guy that looked just like I'm
gonna.
Kick some dude's ass,
but there was A.
is this him?
Is this him or not?
See this guy sucker punches him
and he beats the fuck out of this dude.
Look at him.
He slams down on the ground.
He body slammed him.
Beats the shit out of them.
Is that Dee Snider?
10?
But it comes up when you google them,
like when you Google Dee Snider fight.
Dude,
if it is dee snider has specked respect.
He beat the fuck out of that dude.
That dude sucker punched him.
He body slammed him.
Kick the shit out of him.
The guy was still talking shit,
so he walked up on him again.
I mean this guy sucker punched him.
He beat the shit out of him if that is
him.
It's not that unlike these slides.
I don't like that.
I mean I just didn't like the music,
but after I watched his documentary,
Joe,
I fucking like,
I still don't like the music that I
like.
I'm going to rock.
What does it will go?
They'll rock.
Even that right there is great.
That right there.
That's tremendous.
That's,
that's the opening line of data.
But it was pretty fucking interesting.
They were doing like Long Island,
Wednesday,
Jersey,
3000 seats on Thursday,
another 3000 seats on Friday in the
metropolitan area and then 5,000 on
Saturday and no one would sign them.
Nobody.
That's incredible.
And every time they were going to get
signed,
something else happened.
Like one guy came,
it was an asylum.
He got on the plane,
died of a heart attack.
The other time they were going to play
the garden or something.
They sold that something.
Don't quote me on this.
They sold that something big and
Manhattan,
5,000 seats every a and R guy was going
to come and the drummer got a fucking
infection.
He couldn't play the drums for four
days.
I mean it was just like they kept
getting kicked in the fucking ass.
Boom,
boom.
And finally one day signed them and the
rest happened.
But it's pretty fucking interesting,
man.
Even though you may not like him,
I didn't think much of me that I liked
them when I was a kid.
I liked a bunch of their songs.
I'm sure about one of the records.
That guy's a radio hosts now,
isn't he?
I'm not sure.
I know he was.
I know I called them to his radio
station.
Wants these.
Snyder was a long ass time ago.
Yeah,
it was really cool.
It was crazy.
It was crazy just to talk to dee snider.
I'm like,
I'm talking to him.
I don't remember.
I called him,
I call magic radio show.
One time I called them.
I'm talking to this guy and after 10
minutes I realized this is the guy
that's saying a lot.
I was in jeopardy.
Oh baby.
And he had something else too.
What the fuck was his name?
Do you remember?
Alto.
Nova.
It's just a fantasy.
Put the video on with the video.
Can we end with the video please?
Do you remember the video?
Yes,
I do remember the beginning of it.
What to play a little bit of it,
but we can't play any of the music for
the people at home.
We'll just watch it for us.
Yeah.
After the beginning of that,
life is just a fantasy.
I still remember what I see though in
this video permit.
New Year's eve of 1982 or three volume
young Jamie.
Look at this.
Wow.
This is 83.
Whoa.
That's one of the crazy things about
really good video.
Like this is,
you know,
you see these people.
This is a time capsule.
This is people from the eighties.
You know,
they talk about how music isn't selling
anymore.
Maybe you guys don't.
They don't do these goofy things.
Look at this.
Well,
it's because the only way to get music
back then was you got to buy it.
That's not the case anymore.
It's pretty easy to get music now.
Now it's about making it convenient to
people.
There's Aldo motherfucking Nova with a
leopard leisure suit on bitch.
What?
Look at him.
Handsome motherfucker.
He hopped out demons.
Say Hi to anybody where there's leopard.
Didn't even acknowledge the fact.
Yeah,
I got a leopard skin leotard.
What?
You know?
He's still around Alto Novis.
Just a songwriter now.
Oh Man.
Well you can't take this away from my
watch.
This shit.
This is a.
they're breaking down this door to get
into this warehouse and I'll don't know
if it takes his guitar out.
It gets better,
Dude.
Everybody stand back.
He's going to shoot the wall with his
guitar.
Look at the laser cuts through the door
with his guitar laser.
Here it comes,
baby.
Don't
fast forward to that part.
Either.
Suffer,
suffer to get to this suffering to get
to the song.
No,
you don't remember this dude Jamie,
because you spend too much time on black
twitter.
Okay?
Wearing yeezys.
Look at them.
Did
look at him.
Go up there.
Here it goes.
You don't even know this song to you.
Here we go,
baby.
Jamie's looks the look at Jamie's face.
Put the camera on you.
Can you put the camera on you?
Look at your face.
That's a legitimate reaction to hearing
Aldo Nova in 2016 for the first time.
Come on Bro.
Look at that.
He's got a scarf on.
So leather scarf,
like a snake.
Skin leather is really.
Have a scarf.
Does he?
No.
Look at that outfit.
The leopard print.
It's beautiful.
This song is hypnotic.
Tell me it's not bringing you in.
Bringing you back.
What were you like five when this came
out?
You even born.
You were you 83.
Beginning 83.
You're born in 83.
So this is your baby.
Your baby.
Then when Jamie was born,
this is probably playing
a joke and tell them if they go to Cecil
Csun,
they're pressing joey.
They get two months for free.
Oh,
okay.
I get this special for free.
Free free tomorrow.
So Joey and you'd done for Free Foot
Julian.
That's the Code Joey for two months for
free.
Get on at folks.
Let's blow the shit up.
I'll put it up on twitter and instagram
and all that.
Getting a picture with you right now and
uh,
Jelly,
motherfucking Diaz,
ladies and gentlemen,
Hala,
Bam,
all de Nova in the background.
That's motherfuckers we'd love.
You see a body memory that's happy new
year.
Happy Hanukkah.